Hallo Hendrik.
Hi Kilian.
Wie geht's dir so?
Ich sehe, du hältst dich auch an die Mundschutzpflicht heute.
Das ist sehr vorbildlich von dir.
Sieht maximal dumm aus, wie du dir tatsächlich
den Mundschutz vor der Kamera hängst und ich
immer die Hand vor den Mund halte.
Das ist ja nicht mal mein Mundschutz,
das ist ja mein selbstgenähtes
Geschirrtuch, Mundschutzderivat.
Das ist immerhin die korrektere Bezeichnung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die korrekte Bezeichnung ist,
weil überall, wo man was liest, ist irgendwas anderes.
Für Mundschutz, Mund-Nasenschutz,
Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Arzt, keine Ahnung.
Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Arzt.
Ja, also ich habe offiziell,
wir nehmen jetzt am Sonntag auf
und die Regelung gilt in Sachsen offiziell erst ab morgen,
aber bei mir stand heute schon beim Bäcker an der Tür,
bitte nur mit Mundschutz eintreten.
Ich finde es aber auch nur sinnvoll. Ich finde es aber auch richtig gut,
dass Sachsen da jetzt Vorreiterrolle nimmt
in Deutschland und die Pflicht einführt
als erstes Bundesland. Ach so, wir sind da die Ersten,
die das einführen? Also es kann sein natürlich,
genauso wie mit der Allgemeinverfügung
zur Ausgangsbeschränkung, dass ab morgen
dann spontan auch andere Bundesländer dabei sind.
Aber als es vorgestern angekündigt wurde,
war es das erste Bundesland. Das finde ich sehr cool.
Sachsen hat halt in Deutschland
schon immer eine Vorreiterrolle
eingenommen.
Hoah.
Aber ne, ist ja auch nur richtig so.
Ich finde es ein bisschen weird, dass wir jetzt mit den Lockerungen
ankommen, vor allem für Schulen,
weil was gibt es denn besseres Petri
Petrischalen als Schulen,
um Viren zu verbreiten, aber
Da ist ja irgendein
da ist irgend so ein Petri-Witz
da drin, jetzt.
Ich finde das nicht.
Oh Gott.
Ja, aber
hast du
einen guten
Mundschutz oder sowas?
darf man es ja nicht wirklich nennen, also
oder? Man darf es zumindest nicht
Atemmaske nennen oder sowas, weil es nicht
wirklich eine Atemmaske ist. Hast du irgendwie
einen anständigen Mundschutz? Ich habe so
ein paar Selbstgeschneiderte, die mir
meine Mutter und meine Oma tatsächlich zugeschickt
haben.
Die sind auch ganz okay. Die haben tatsächlich auch mit so einem
Metallbügel drin, dass sie an der Nase besser abdichten.
Aber die wirkt
also ich meine mit Mundschutz, beziehungsweise
nennen wir es einfach mal Maske,
keine Ahnung. Ich glaube Mundschutz darf man sagen.
Man darf es bloß nicht Atemmaske sagen.
Es ist ja auch Nasenschutz gleich mit. Also wer das Ding über die Nase zieht, der hat ja eh diese Sinhaltigkeit nicht ganz verstanden. Aber das Problem, was die Dinge halt oftmals haben, ist, in geschlossenen Räumen bringt dir das echt nicht viel, weil die Luft, die du ausstößt, suchst dich eh den geringsten Weg des Widerstands und das geht normalerweise neben der Nase dann einfach oben wieder raus.
Also es bringt schon definitiv mehr als gar nichts, das absolut. Aber die ist jetzt nicht so ein Allheilmittel, leider. Also muss man einfach drauf wissen, wenn du in einem geschlossenen Raum bist mit einer Person, die infektiös ist, dann hast du eigentlich quasi schon verloren.
Nicht unbedingt. Es gab wohl auch Studien, die gezeigt haben, wenn du das, wenn du halt anständigen Mundschutz trägst, dass dann sich die, aber I'm not a virologist, virologist, also das Traumäßig, virologe, ich bin kein Virologe.
Was ich auf jeden Fall sehr aufschlussreich fand, waren so Visualisierungen, wo sie jemanden gezeigt haben, der einfach normal redet, so wie wir jetzt.
Und dann kann man ja mit so einem Schliereneffekt, mit so einem Kamerabild die Luftbewegung, die man produziert, selber visualisieren.
Und dann sieht man wirklich, dass man selbst beim normalen Sprechen schon auf einem Radius von gut über einem Meter entweder Luft bewegt, pustet oder manchmal auch unweigerlich spuckt.
Und sobald du einfach nur so ein bisschen Stoff vor dem Mund hast, macht das schon einen relativ großen Unterschied.
Naja, aber das Problem ist halt, dass die Tröpfchen, die du ausstoßt, die fliegen halt nicht einfach nur kurz aus dir raus und landen dann irgendwo,
sondern die schweben halt stundenlang in der Luft rum, weil die halt leicht genug sind.
Genau, deswegen möchte man irgendwie nicht in einem Raum mit stehender Luft sein, wo viele Leute durchkommen.
Ja, lüften macht einen riesen Unterschied tatsächlich. Das bringt echt was.
Aber die Maskenpflicht, die wir ab morgen ja jetzt hier zu Lande, also in Sachsen haben,
betrifft ja auch in erster Linie wirklich nur geschlossene Räume, sprich ÖPNV und Einzelhandel.
Zum draußen rumlaufen brauchst du sie nicht tragen.
Das wäre auch, glaube ich, Maskenverschwendung.
Das bringt es auch nicht so wirklich.
Also wenn du dich in Läden aufhältst, also einkaufen gehst, Maske dran und im Bus, in der Bahn, Maske drauf.
Aber ja, genau, das ist auch eigentlich das Relevanteste für den Schutz anderer.
Ich hatte auch gestern einen schönen Diskurs auf Twitter, da hat dann Bundesdresden geschrieben, MNS, also Hashtag Community Maske, ist ab dem 20.04. in Sachsischen ÖPNV verpflichtend.
Die DVB AG wird ab Montag mit Serviceteams und Ticketkontrolleuren freundlich auf die MNS-Pflicht hinweisen und gegebenenfalls soweit vorrätig wohl mit einer MNS aushelfen können, sagte uns der DVB-Chat.
Hat die dann ein cooles DVB-Logo drauf?
Keine Ahnung, also so eine Maske hätte ich ja fast gerne, muss ich sagen.
Und da habe ich dann so mal ein bisschen, ich frotzle ja gerne mit Leuten auf Twitter rum,
da habe ich dann unten drunter geschrieben, ah, wer also keiner hat, kann sich also bei der nächsten Straßenbahn eine abholen,
Hashtag Maskenlieferdienst.
Na gut.
Ist die DVB auf Twitter direkt ein bisschen defensiv geworden und hat dann gesagt,
naja, so im Zweifelsfall kannst du ja alternativ auch ein Halsdu oder einen Schal benutzen.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich am Freitag mir eine lokal gemachte Maske bei einem Schneider bei mir um die Ecke gekauft.
Oh, fancy.
War zufällig, na ne, ich war eigentlich Döner essen, aber da ist so eine Reinigungsänderungsschneiderei slash Reinigung irgendwie nebenan, genau.
Und die hatten schon ein Schild am Fenster, dass die Masken verkaufen und die sind aus alten Herrenhemden geschneidert oder aus Herrenhemden geschneidert und sind echt gut genäht mit einem echten Gummi.
Das habe ich selber nicht hingekriegt, weil ich keine
Gummis hatte.
Und jetzt habe ich so eine.
Das ist so ein bisschen, naja, Pastellgrün hätte
ich mir vielleicht was an einem anderen Stoff aussuchen können,
aber die anderen Muster waren noch schlimmer.
Es scheint ja irgendwie so ein Trend zu sein
momentan, wer hat die schicksten
Gesichtsmasken?
Wenn man mal so ein geiles,
wie heißen
diese floralen 70er
Jahre Muster, du hattest auch so eine Maske.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt, aber ich finde es auch
sehr schick. Es ist tatsächlich, wie gestern
meinen, das Fashion Statement 2020.
Jetzt hier, wer die schickste Maske hat,
das ist so aktuelle Mode.
Kumpel und Kollege von mir hat auch,
da hat die
Partnerin
sich Stoff besorgt,
vor Wochen und Monaten schon, für eigentlich andere
Bastelprojekte und jetzt ist sowieso
Näh-Savvy und
hat eine Nähmaschine da, der hatte
irgendwie eine ganze Kollektion richtig geilen
Masken.
MNS-en.
MNS.
Das ist noch gar nicht bescheuert. Kann man das irgendwie mit Vokalen auffüllen?
Monaden fast draus machen oder so?
Naja, Hashtag Community Maske.
Ah, okay, oder so.
Hashtag Hashtag Community Maske.
Was ist denn sonst neben Corona so passiert?
Das ist ja hier jetzt das Thema, was die Welt beschäftigt immer noch und wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile.
Also eine wichtige Metrik beim Podcast momentan ist das Verhältnis von Corona zu nicht Corona related im Content.
Und ich glaube, wir machen am besten jetzt einen Schnitt.
und reden ab jetzt nicht mehr über Corona.
Da fällt mir ein, dass ich an dieser Stelle...
Das werden wir nicht schaffen.
Irgendwo wird es wieder relevant werden.
Aber das Thema als solches können wir einfach erstmal abhaken.
Also zumindest für diese Folge.
Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass sich irgendwie so viele coole Themen ergeben.
Irgendwie scheint sehr vielen Leuten gerade sehr langweilig zu sein,
habe ich den Eindruck.
Naja, langweilig.
Ich könnte gleich das erste Thema aufgreifen.
Dank der Krise springen Leute ja auf dezentrale Möglichkeiten,
um sich zu unterhalten, so wie wir jetzt gerade,
und nutzen so Software wie Zoom.
Und Zoom ist ja so unglaublich
populär kurzzeitig geworden.
Was ist denn dann sowas dezentral?
Dezentral im Sinne,
dass wir nicht zusammensitzen, meine ich.
Ach so.
In sowas wie Jitsi kannst du natürlich auch dezentral hosten,
aber dezentral in dem Sinne,
dass wir uns nicht an einem Ort treffen.
Ich glaube, du meinst eher Remote oder?
Ja, ja.
Ich bezeichne sowas gerne als dezentral.
Ich glaube, dezentral ist da ein bisschen fehleitend,
weil Dezentral, es basiert ja schon auf einem zentralen Cloud-Dienst.
Ja, aber in einem anderen Kontext.
Aber egal, gut, hast du recht.
Wir treffen uns remote und viele Leute machen solche Remote-Treffen
eben über den tollen Plattform-Service Zoom.
Und Zoom ist netterweise immer wieder gerade in den Medien
durch den neuen Security Vulnerability und ein neues Problem,
das jemand gefunden hat und schon wieder eine dumme Firmenpolitik.
Und das finde ich großartig.
Sehr amüsant.
Ich weiß, dass du nicht unbedingt schlechte Dinge über Konkurrenten sagen möchtest.
Also ich habe bloß gesagt, dass ich mich nicht unbedingt in diesem Podcast zu Zoom äußern werde,
auch wenn es da wahrscheinlich viel zu äußern gäbe.
Aber dadurch, dass ich an einem Konkurrenzprodukt von Zoom arbeite
und allgemein nicht unbedingt über Arbeit reden möchte in diesem Podcast.
Nee, wir müssen auch nicht viel darüber sagen.
Ich finde es witzig, dass das halt immer wieder ein neues Thema hochkommt
und gerade so witzige Sachen wie,
die Konferenz-IDs sind halt einfach erratbar oder durchnummerierbar gewesen.
und Passwörter gab es nicht und du konntest
einfach mal schauen, was es alles gibt an Konferenzen,
was gerade läuft. Wie haben die Leute
genannt? War Dialing.
So quasi angelernt, War Driving oder andere
ähnliche War-Sternchen-Begriffe.
Ist das nicht Zoom-Bombing? Oder Zoom-Bombing
war auch ein Begriff, genau. Irgendwie, da gab es dann
Berichte von Leuten, die ihre Masterarbeit
verteidigt haben und plötzlich malte irgendwer einen Penis
in den Screenshare rein. Du bist gerade in deiner
PhD-Defense und plötzlich kommen da drei
Leute rein und jählen rassistischen Bullshit.
Rufen rassistischen Bullshit. Ja, da gab es definitiv
Blockpost drüber. Grandios sowas.
Nee, das haben sie
mittlerweile, glaube ich, in den Griff bekommen und dann haben sie
wieder andere Probleme mit irgendwelchen Windows
Zugängen,
Vulnerabilities, Krams. Also ich habe da auch
kündig den Überblick verloren, was Zoom alles da
falsch macht, aber da war schon irgendwie eine ganze
Latte von Dingen. Ich hätte eigentlich
Links mal im Pad sammeln müssen hier,
aber ich habe jetzt nur noch das für das, dieses eine
Tool, was jemand geschrieben hat, ZWardial,
was es einfach komplett automatisiert hat,
sich da durchzurufen.
Aber ich meine, nur durch solche passenden Sachen
halt, also schaffst du es,
dass Vulnerabilities auch schnell gefixt werden,
wenn sie sehr einfach
auszunutzen sind.
Ja,
auf jeden Fall. Sie haben sich zumindest irgendwie,
ah ne, ich werde nichts sagen.
Ich sage nichts.
Na okay, dann lassen wir mal
das Thema, wird ja sicherlich noch weiter beschäftigen
andere. Es wird gegebenenfalls
noch weitere Nachrichten dazu geben im Laufe
der nächsten Wochen, wer weiß.
Sind das für ein Vorscheidungen gewesen?
Achso, ne.
Fuck, ich meinte, ich weiß natürlich nichts, aber diese Nachrichten kamen einfach mit einer derartigen Konsistenz, dass es auch weitere Nachrichten geben wird.
Ja, okay, das kann ich absolut nachvollziehen.
Genau. Was ich als spannendes Thema fand, was wir noch nicht hatten bei der letzten Sendung, dass es jetzt leider auch wieder so ein bisschen Corona-related ist, diese ganzen Debatten über Corona-Apps und das ist wahrscheinlich auch was für unsere Hörerschaft schon so ein bisschen so ein leidiges Thema sein könnte.
Wahrscheinlich habt ihr euch alle schon relativ intensiv mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt.
Aber was ich gerade merke, ist, dass man als, das ist gerade so ein bisschen wie, wenn man zu Weihnachten zu Hause ist und den Eltern den Computer repariert,
ist es momentan so, dass man seinen Freunden die Unterschiede zwischen unterschiedlichen Corona-Apps erklären muss.
Ist dir das auch schon passiert?
Okay.
Also ich hatte jetzt schon mehrmals die Situation, dass ich mich mit nicht technischen Freunden unterhalten habe
und dann die Unterschiede zwischen diesen unterschiedlichen Apps,
die es gibt oder die es geben könnte oder geben sollte, erklärt habe.
Und jetzt scheint irgendwie völlig die Hölle zugefroren zu sein.
Es gibt irgendwie eine Collab zwischen Apple und Google in dem Bereich.
Völlig die Hölle zugefroren.
Die beiden Firmen machen ziemlich viel miteinander.
Aber gut, solche Announcements kriegt man nicht ganz so häufig.
Hast du dir durchgelesen, was die machen?
Ja, also die große Idee,
was viele Firmen ja auch an viele kleinere Läden versucht haben umzusetzen,
war ja so ein Contract Tracing zu machen.
Contract Tracing im Sinne von, jeder hat ein Smartphone.
Und warum können die nicht im Hintergrund einfach mal die Nähe zueinander mittracken?
Und wenn dann irgendwer meint, wenn irgendwer positiv getestet wird,
schaut man einfach, welche Kontakte vorher vorlagen
und benachrichtigt all die Leute.
Und somit herauszufinden, wer potenziell auch infiziert sein könnte
und diese Infektionsketten schneller nachvollziehen kann,
um Leute zu isolieren und das Ganze abzubremsen.
Und das ist halt an vielen, vielen Stellen gescheitert.
Natürlich das klassische Beispiel von wegen,
du hast zu wenig Leute, die das nutzen,
dann kannst du das ganze Konzept wieder in die Tonne werfen.
Für die Community war das immer das Hauptproblem.
Und auf der anderen Seite,
dass es technisch einfach nicht so einfach umzusetzen ist,
wie man dachte.
Auf Android-Geräten hatte man tatsächlich die Möglichkeiten dazu,
das ständig signal zu broadcasten,
mitzuhören im Hintergrund über Bluetooth.
da Dinge zu machen, aber auf iOS
war das Teil tatsächlich nicht so
einfach möglich, nur indem die App die ganze
Zeit läuft. Und dann gab es tatsächlich Firmen,
die haben halt dann hier dazu geraten,
hier, mach die App auf, jetzt legst du dein Handy mit dem
Display nach unten in deine Tasche und
dann gehst du durch die Welt. Also,
dass jemand macht. So ein Quatsch.
Also, vielversprechend ist es dann wirklich nur,
wenn du Support vom Betriebssystem in der Stelle
hast. Eben, das muss über die Plattformwender gehen.
Und genau das kam da eben als das Announcement raus, was du gerade
meintest. Apple und Google haben da was angekündigt,
dass sie da zusammen kooperieren wollen
und sowas ins System zu integrieren und was ich sehr, sehr
angenehm dabei finde. Typisch
Apple, will ich jetzt mal sagen.
Ich will ja keine Werbung machen an der Stelle, aber das passt halt
in deren MO, dass sie da halt versuchen,
auch die Privacy mit so ein bisschen im Blick zu halten.
Und
Modus operandi, oder? Ist das glaube ich
kurz. Aber vielleicht ist die Software was ähnliches.
Aber hätte ich jetzt zumindest so.
So wird es genutzt.
Okay, genau.
Passt in deren MO.
Die nehme ich gerne
diese Identifier, die du die ganze Zeit durch die Kante schickst,
die werden auch regelmäßig gerotated,
sodass du nicht
trackbar bist und nicht jemanden nachvollziehen kannst,
wo du dich im Alltag aufhältst.
Das ist natürlich äußerst relevant für sowas.
Inwiefern das halt ins Betriebssystem
dann wirklich integriert wird, dass es auch ohne
App-Support läuft und Apps
maximal nur darauf die Daten zugreifen können
und wie das dann alles
gemacht wird, das steht noch gar nicht fest.
Das war jetzt bloß hier Hinweise von wegen
die beiden einigen sich auf Datenformate
und wie diese Daten geschickt und gesammelt und getrackt werden,
aber gar nicht, wie das auf dem Frontend benutzt wird.
Das ist dann einfach gar nichts.
Obwohl es ja wirklich sinnvoll wäre, wenn du willst,
dass es ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung nutzt,
wäre, dass es nicht 11 Apps gibt,
die irgendwie anbieten, dass es geht,
vor allem, weil das auch zu Verwirrungen führt,
sondern dass du einfach ein Betriebssystem-Update bekommst
und dann kannst du genauso, wie du es WLAN anmachst,
kannst du das Contract Tracing anmachen oder ausmachen.
Das wäre vielleicht sinnvoll.
Oder du machst halt, dass es nur im Stromsprachmodus aus ist.
Oder was weiß ich.
Also ich meine, es kann auch Leute geben,
es soll auch gerne Leute geben, die sagen,
ich will das nicht, ich will das aushaben.
Es ist ein Tracking Feature, es muss ein Update geben.
Sehe ich genauso.
Genau.
Aber gerade, weil ich auch so Aussagen gehört habe.
Also wir können das nochmal ganz kurz zusammenfassen.
Bloß um mal diese drei Kategorien mal namentlich zu benennen,
damit wir irgendwie hier die Terminologie klar kriegen.
Es gibt Tracking-Apps, das waren so die ersten Vorschläge, teilweise vom Robert-Koch-Institut.
Das waren die, ich mache einfach Location-Tracking von jeder Person, damit weiß ich immer, wo grob jeder war.
Und dann könnte ich theoretisch damit irgendwie so übereinschneidende Punkte messen.
Wir waren im gleichen Gebäude zur gleichen Zeit oder sowas.
Das ist relativ schnell verworfen worden oder hoffentlich verworfen worden.
Tatsächlich wurde zumindest harsche Kritik bekommen, weil es erstens Positionsdaten nicht genau genug sind für solche Ermittlungen.
Theoretisch kannst du nicht sauer trennschhaft unterscheiden, ob du nun ein Stockwerk höher oder tiefer bist oder ob wir überhaupt nahe genug an der gleichen Stelle waren.
Normalerweise, wenn du irgendwie GPS-Daten, also zivile GPS-Daten für Navigation verwendest, ist es ja auch so, dass dein Kartenprogramm einigermaßen rät, dass du wahrscheinlich gerade auf der Straße bist und nicht auf dem Gehweg auf etwas anderes bist.
Das wird immer auf der Straße zurückgemittelt.
Genau, dementsprechend, also alles, was auf GPS oder auf Location-Daten basiert, ist an und für sich Quatsch und es sind halt mehr persönliche Daten als nützliche Daten dabei und es werden dann auch viel zu viele, viel zu ungenaue Daten.
Also sie sind eher schädlich als nützlich und dementsprechend gab es zum einen mehrere Vorschläge, glaube ich, aus diesem We-Against-Virus-Hackathon und sind auch tatsächlich auch schon in der Tagesschau und so diskutiert worden.
Ich empfehle wieder mal Logbuch-Netzpolitik, da wurde das auch schon relativ gut auseinanderklamüsert. Aber so ähnlich klingen also diese Vorschläge von Google und Apple. Wir machen also so einen Bluetooth-Low-Energy-Ping und jeder merkt sich einfach nur die ganzen Pings, die er empfängt.
und dann ist es egal, ob da 35 unterschiedliche Keys dieselbe Person sind.
Was du einfach machst, ist, dass du dir merkst, was du alles empfängst
und irgendwann gehst du eventuell, wenn du diagnostiziert wurdest, zum Arzt
und der Arzt signiert eventuell deinen Key, vielleicht deinen Root-Key
und dann werden quasi alle deine Pings öffentlich gelegt
und jeder, der weiß, dass er mit dir in Kontakt war, weiß, dass er potenziell gefährdet ist.
Das ist dann die maximal Privacy oder die hoffentlich möglichst Privacy-sichere Variante, die auch mit am genauesten ist.
Und dann gab es noch diese Robert-Koch-Corona-App.
Die Datenspende meinst du?
Diese Datenspende-App, die völlig unnötig irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen rauskam, wo Leute jetzt denken, dass sie eine Corona-App installiert haben und alles gut ist, obwohl es überhaupt nichts mit dem zu tun hat, wovon wir hier reden.
Weil dann nämlich einfach von
irgendwelchen Gesundheitstrackern Daten einfach mal
gespendet werden. Das ist nützlich für
irgendwen, der irgendwo eine Studie macht, aber nicht für diejenigen,
die sich irgendwie
sicher fühlen wollen, dass
sie jetzt irgendwie nicht in Kontakt
mit irgendwelchen Infizierten sind.
Das sind so diese drei Kategorien und ich glaube
die sinnvollste und worauf jetzt die
Sachen hinausarbeiten werden, wird diese
Bluetooth-basierte Variante sein.
Und da wäre es
halt wirklich gut, wenn wir da nicht irgendwie
35 Apps haben, sondern wenn es irgendwie ein Feature
Dann könnte man überlegen, dass man vielleicht eine landesweite oder eine europaweite Infrastruktur macht, um diese Keys offen zu legen. Weil im Endeffekt, was du mit den Daten konkret machst, muss gar nicht so genau festgelegt werden. Wichtig ist, dass jeder irgendwie trackt, mit wem er Kontakt hatte.
Da ist die Frage, was man mit den Daten auch dann machen kann. Letztendlich wollen Datingfirmen sowas auch schon seit Jahren machen. Wen hast du den Tag über gesehen und war da jemand dabei, den du toll fandest?
Ah ja, diese typische, aus der Katz, diese Anzeige.
Ich saß Donnerstag früh um 8.30 Uhr in der 61.
Ich habe dich gesehen, du druckst eine Blauhose.
Und ja, stimmt, da könnte man jetzt gucken.
Oh Gott, könnte man das irgendwie angreifen?
Ich habe dann definitiv deinen Key-Empfang, aber ich weiß nicht.
Wenn du die Daten offenlegen möchtest und darüber,
Also wenn du, naja, nee, ist ja die Frage,
wie du das sammelnst und was du für Möglichkeiten da hast.
Das wäre cool.
Ich könnte sagen, ah, ich habe zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
habe ich diese Keys empfangen.
Das heißt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt habe ich garantiert
von dieser hübschen Frau die Keys mitempfangen.
Und jetzt könnte man irgendwie schauen, ob die,
aber die Person veröffentlicht ihre Keys ja auch erst dann,
wenn sie sich irgendwie als Fall meldet oder sowas.
Sonst gibt es ja...
Ich finde die Frage, was man für eine Plattform bietet
für andere Sachen, die dann darauf aufbauen könnten.
Wenn man jetzt einfach nur die Daten sammelt,
die Betriebssysteme machen das, machen das intern
und rein theoretisch und stellen halt die öffentlichen Möglichkeiten
dafür bereit, darüber Contact Tracing zu betreiben,
dann würde man das ja auch in Zukunft für andere Sachen
neben Corona haben wollen.
Das ist ja hoffentlich der letzte, aber ist ja wahrscheinlich nicht die letzte Pandemie, die wir in unserer Lebenszeit haben werden, gerade wenn der Planet so voll ist, wie er aktuell ist.
Witzigerweise ist die letzte ziemlich genau 100 Jahre her.
Das fand ich auch interessant, dass es irgendwie so immer so auf die 20er Jahreszahl haut.
Aber das war irgendwie auch so 26, 27, 28, 29, 20 und 20, 20.
Irgendwie so, what the fuck, wie kann das alle ziemlich exakt 100 Jahre sowas kommen?
Ja, bei der letzten Pandemie war gleichzeitig noch ein Weltkrieg. Glücklicherweise haben wir das dieses Mal ausgelassen.
Ja, das ist nice, immerhin.
Genau, also wichtig ist, dass die Keys rotiert werden bei den Bluetooth-Apps.
Und ansonsten, also ich weiß sonst von noch nicht weiteren Entwicklungen.
Es gab noch keine öffentliche Verlautbarung,
dass es irgendwelche fertigen Apps oder Betriebssystem-Updates gibt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie es bei Android wirklich ausgerollt werden soll.
Da könnte ich mir...
Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Das ist ja alles schwierig.
Ich könnte mir maximal vorstellen, dass es eine,
dass es nicht
direkt über ein Betriebssystem-Update
geht, weil das ist bei Android ja besagterweise
etwas schwierig, aber da könnte ich mir fast
vorstellen, dass es eine
Google-sanktionierte App gibt,
die mit geheimem Google-Wissen
auf Sachen und APIs zugreifen
kann, auf die sonst niemand zugreifen kann
bislang.
Aber ob das wirklich funktioniert, weiß ich nicht.
Da habe ich auch zu wenig Ahnung von Android
und Deployment, wie was da
wie das geregelt wird, aber prinzipiell klar.
Von einer groben Idee her.
Genau.
Dann gibt es noch diese ganzen
Billigtelefone, die die Leute auch noch haben. Also es wird alles nicht so
gut funktionieren, wie du denkst.
Wir leben ja trotzdem in einer Welt, wo Leute
jetzt immer mit, also im Vergleich zu vor ein paar
Jahren mit Technik am Mann rumrennen.
Jederzeit, überall.
Oder eine Frau.
Ja, Mann mit einem N, obwohl es grammatikalisch
falsch war.
Ja, ich habe mir ab und zu
schon mal überlegt, ich habe
auch schon ein, zwei Mal überlegt, wie würde das
eigentlich, was wäre eigentlich passiert,
wenn diese Pandemie,
wir reden immer noch drüber, wenn die
vor 15 Jahren passiert wäre,
oder vor 10 Jahren, vor dem
ersten iPhone,
wenn die passiert wäre, als
allgemeine Videokonferenzen
noch nicht so ohne weiteres möglich waren,
als noch nicht jeder
einen YouTube-Stream machen konnte, mal eben von zu Hause,
da wäre
wesentlich mehr eingebrochen. Entweder hätten wir dann
komplett auf irgendwelche Maßnahmen verzichtet und gesagt,
nee, die Leute müssen wieder zurück zur Schule gehen,
sonst können sie nicht unterrichtet werden.
Wir können ja schließlich nicht irgendwie die Leute
übers Telefon unterrichten oder solche Sachen machen.
Mit Videokonferenzen und Screensharing funktioniert das einigermaßen.
Ich erinnere mich an so eine Sache,
die wir, das war aber gefühlt so in der Grundschule,
wo wir das mal hatten in der Schule,
oder vielleicht auch ein bisschen später,
dass wir über so eine Schule aus Australien was behandelt haben.
Das ist so eine Schule irgendwo mitten Zentralaustralien, also Pampa, wo keine Städte sind.
Und die ist irgendwie so über so einen Bereich von mehreren hundert Kilometern, ist das Einzugsgebiet dieser Schule.
Und die Schüler, für die ist es halt einfach gar nicht praktikabel, zu einem Schulgebäude zu kommen.
Deswegen existiert dieses Schulgebäude auch gar nicht.
Und die machen halt seit Jahren Unterricht über Funkgeräte.
Die haben da wirklich so Ham Radio und machen darüber Unterricht.
Also die sind Vorreiter, was Remote-Unterricht angeht.
Das geht auch nur so, funktioniert bei denen.
Aber das geht auch nur akustisch, oder?
Ja, die machen das rein akustisch.
Die haben dann, schicken die sich irgendwie...
Die haben den Lehrer nie gesehen.
Ich glaube, es hieß, glaube ich, der Lehrer oder die Lehrer,
die traveln übers Jahr hinweg mal rum
und lernen die Schüler mal persönlich kennen,
irgendwann im Laufe des Jahres.
Aber die Schüler haben einander teilweise auch nie gesehen.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch besser,
als wenn die ganzen Leute ihre Kinder zu Hause erziehen,
wie es das in USA macht.
Auf jeden Fall.
Homeschooling ist so ein Unding.
Nee, das ist ein ganz anderer Rant.
Das Thema machen wir mal nicht auf.
Aber ich habe auch schon
so Aussagen von Leuten gehört, ja ich frage mich, wie die Leute,
die permanent ihre Kinder zu Hause unterrichten,
wie die das machen. Ich kriege das überhaupt nicht hin,
die Kinder sind so anstrengend.
Und ich denke mir jetzt mal, das stimmt, das ist echt ein Ding,
was es in den USA gibt. Das ist so bescheuert.
Ja.
Es gibt auch so ähnliche Dinge tatsächlich
so ein bisschen hier, teilweise so
ein bisschen underground, weil es halt nicht
ganz legal ist, weil die Schulpflicht ja existiert.
aber halbwegs ähnliche
Konzepte, jetzt komme ich gerade auf den Begriffen
ich glaube freies Lernen oder so ähnlich
es gibt teilweise so
Familien, die wohnen an der Grenze nach
Frankreich und
machen das so halb
auf der einen Seite, halb auf der anderen Seite
irgendwie war das so weirde Situation
aber ja
ich weiß auch
weil sie die Kinder sonst in Frankreich zur Schule
schicken könnten oder wollten, aber nicht
dürfen, weil sie in Deutschland wohnt. Irgendwie so
Grenzsituationen, dass sie da irgendwie
sowohl die physische als auch die
legale Grenzsituation ausnutzen.
Oh man.
Eine Sache, die ich noch gesehen habe, die relativ lustig war,
es gibt von Apple auch
Face Shields. Hast du die dir
angeguckt? Ich fand den
Tweet von, oder wie gesagt, das ist ein
Ankündigungsvideo von Tim Cook super cool,
wo er sich hinstellt und
so quasi selbst hier quasi
Kamera vor das Gesicht halten und mal kurz
erklären, was sie gemacht haben, dass sie halt die
Ressourcen haben. Sie haben haufenweise Industrial
Design-Leute und warum nicht
mal diese Ressourcen auf solche Probleme
werfen, haben sie gemacht, haben
eigene Face Shields entworfen und was Apple halt auch
hat, also
fast im kompletten Gegenteil zu anderen
gigantischen Firmen, ist eine
unglaublich krasse Supply Chain für Materialien.
Was sie da sourcen und
produzieren können, das kann sonst fast
niemand auf der Skala machen.
Und da haben sie halt
jetzt Masken entworfen
und produziert, die
Face Shields, jetzt diese
Plastik-Schilde vorm Gesicht für Ärzte
im Krankenhaus, die
gut lagerbar sind,
weil sie sich flach lagern lassen im Vergleich zu
anderen. Da passen 50 Stück in die Kiste.
Das ist quasi so ein Bogen, den du dir
um die Stirn machst mit so einem einfachen
Stück durchsichtige Plaste
vorm Gesicht, oder? Exakt, genau.
Du musst damit mal ein Bild vor Augen haben. Da gab es auch
ein Video von dem Smarter
Everyday-Typen, der irgendwie so einen Aufruf
gemacht hat, dass Leute diese Ränder
3D drucken und die haben dann auch
irgendwie so eine Supply Chain aufgemacht, wo sie die ganzen
Sachen erstmal sammeln, dann desinfizieren
und dann irgendwie ein Paket packen
und über irgendwelche lokalen
Krankenhausanbieter oder sowas verteilen.
Da habe ich mich allerdings schon so ein bisschen gefragt,
also warte mal, so ein Face Shield
ist quasi dieser Stirnbalken
und dann irgendwie klemmst du da
so ein Stückchen Plaste rein.
So ein Stückchen Plaste, ja.
Also so eine,
also der eigentliche Face Shield ist ein Stück
durchsichtiges Plaste, was du an diesen Stirnbalken
festmachst. Genau. Und
die Lösung, die
man sich da ausgedacht hat, ist ja, die ist
eigentlich, ja, er hat auch gesagt, macht
die Dinger einfach, selbst wenn euch was Besseres einfällt,
darum geht's jetzt nicht.
Wenn ihr 3D-Drucker habt,
dann stellt bitte einfach mal diese Dinger her. Aber ich hab mir gedacht,
du musst ja nicht diese ganzen Bögen
neu herstellen. Du brauchst ja eigentlich nur
diese... Es geht
aber auch um die Anzahl, die fehlt. Also die
Schilde musst du sicherlich auch desinfizieren und
reinigen, logischerweise. Aber
allein die Menge von den Dingern
halt überall.
Mensch und Schild ist halt auch nicht für den Allgemeingebrauch
sinnvoll. Die sind ja nur relevant, wenn du
vor jemandem bist, der dich anhustet und dann
das Ding erwischt und nicht dich mit
großen Tropfen. Dahinter trägst du
ja trotzdem noch eine Maske
und eine Schutzbrille.
Es ist auf jeden Fall spannend zu sehen, wie
in den USA und solche Storys, habe ich leider aus
Deutschland noch nicht wirklich gehört,
große Industrie
Firmen gerade mobil
machen, um gewisse Sachen herzustellen.
um irgendwie Teile für Ventilatoren herzustellen.
Es gab einen guten Podcast, war das Planet Money oder irgendeiner,
wo jetzt organisiert durch Ford oder so die Herstellung von Ventilatoren organisiert werden.
Also Ford macht quasi nur das Management und die Organisation
und die rufen unterschiedliche Zulieferanten von sich an und sagen,
ihr macht mal bitte das, ihr macht mal bitte das und dann wird das hier irgendwie assembled.
Kennst du solche Geschichten aus Deutschland irgendwie,
dass jetzt hier losgerannt wird, um
irgendwelche Sachen herzustellen? Ich meine,
ich hätte irgendwas gehört, wüsste aber gerade nicht,
was das genau war. Was mir aber allerdings einfällt,
war diese eine tolle Firma,
ich hoffe, es ist jetzt nicht falsch,
ich meine, es war eine italienische
Firma, die solche
Respiratoren hergestellt hat,
die jetzt angefangen hat,
das ist schon wieder zwei Wochen her oder so, die angefangen hat,
Leute zu verklagen, die Dinge halt selbst hergestellt
haben, weil das ist ja ihre
IP. Das geht ja gar nicht, dass
sie das irgendwie selber machen.
sagt mal, kriegt ihr mit, was ihr gerade,
ihr könnt das Zeug nicht selber liefern, weil ihr
nicht die Ressourcen habt, das schnell genug zu produzieren.
Das heißt, ihr seid quasi ausverkauft,
ihr arbeitet am Limit, ihr macht so viel Gewinn,
wie physisch möglich ist,
mehr geht nicht, aber trotzdem habt ihr
noch die Möglichkeiten, anderen Leuten
legal auf die Füße zu treten. Kriegt ihr überhaupt
nicht mit, was gerade weltweit passiert, ihr Idioten?
Oh Mann.
Wow.
Gut.
Was ich gerade sehe, weil ich gerade den Link
ins Pad kopiert haben zu dem Google Announcement,
was ich jetzt irgendwie da toll finde, ist, dass
Googles Blog die Domain blog.google
hat. Ich finde es einfach nur cool.
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist schon sehr editär.
Ich meine, seine eigene Top-Level-Domain
zu haben, ist nicht schwer. Du brauchst bloß
50.000 Dollar oder sowas und dann
hast du eine. Ja, oder du übernimmst sowas.
Das habe ich auch letztens gesehen
von
.ai.
Was war denn das? Angila oder
sowas? Wahrscheinlich auch ein Land, was es nicht mehr gibt.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Insel, aber gefährliches, geografisches Halbwissen hier.
Das ist ein so cooler Hacker, der da die TLD übernommen hat.
Der ist dahin, hat Infrastruktur hingestellt und hat alte Computer an Schulen gespendet.
Lebt seitdem, glaube ich, dort.
Ich muss den Namen nochmal raussuchen.
Gehen wir einfach mal auf AI. im Browser.
Genau, Vinscate steht ganz unten.
AI.
Wunderschöne Seite.
Genau, wenn du AI. eingibst, dann kommst du auf die Domain AI, weil AI einzugeben, normalerweise ist das wahrscheinlich dann zu Search Fallback.
Also es gibt definitiv AI.Google.
Nee, nee, einfach nur AI. Geht auf die Domain AI. Eine TLD ist ja auch nur eine Domain. Jede normale Domain ist ja quasi eine Subdomain auf der TLD.
Ja, ich muss bloß meinen Browser erstmal davon überzeugen, dass er AI. nicht in meiner Search Engine.
Dann kriege ich auch noch ein Protokoll davor, einfach HTTP.
HTTP.doppelpunkt.
ist das eine valide URL?
Ja, kann sie den Punkt wahrscheinlich sogar beklassen.
Tatsächlich Offshore Information Services.
Aber es ist mega geil und dieser Typ
Winskate da unten.
Also eine valide URL
kann nach dem,
nach der TLD noch einen Punkt haben.
Ja, ja, der Punkt
hinten dran ist einfach nur quasi dann,
ja, okay, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was
hier RFC-Content dazu angeht,
aber zumindest routet man
da zu einer TLD direkt,
wenn du einfach einen Punkt dahinter eingeschwirst.
Witzig. Jetzt möchte ich jetzt glattweg mal irgendwie damit irgendwelche URL-Parser trollen, die damit nicht rechnen.
Du kannst tatsächlich akronomisier.bar.slash eingeben und es geht. Ich bin gerade total geflasht davon. Egal, sorry.
Nee, aber was witzig ist, ist der Typ Vince Kate, der unten verlinkt ist, dessen Telefonnummer auch auf AI steht, der managt quasi komplett die TLD AI und der hat einen, wahrscheinlich vermute mal Bekannter oder Online-Bekannter oder wie auch immer von dem, ein Typ namens Ian, hat über ihn die E-Mail-Adresse bekommen, n.ai, also Ian rückwärts.
Und das ist halt schon eine ziemlich geile Mailadresse,
wenn du einfach nur ein Buchstabe at TLD,
ich will sowas auch haben.
Und vor allem ist dieser I-Inhalt dahergegangen,
hat bei irgendeinem Linux-E-Mail-Standard-Desktop-Client,
Epiphany oder so, oder wie das heißt, glaube ich,
oder so ähnlich, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Da hat er auf die Mailingliste geschrieben,
dass seine E-Mail nicht erst valide erkannt wird.
Das ist halt so ein typisches Brachbeispiel von wegen,
wie validiert ihr E-Mail-Adressen?
Jeder validiert E-Mail-Adressen halt falsch.
Du kannst E-Mail-Adressen nicht validieren.
Du kannst maximal bei dir halt schauen,
ob eine E-Mail dazu gesendet werden kann.
Das ist ein anderes Quatsch.
Du kannst
ihn vielleicht fragen, ob du
n.ai
slash lick als Weiterleitung
bekommst. Das ist nämlich Kilian rückwärts.
Wäre schon
ziemlich cool.
Meine Sammlung an Vanity-E-Mail-Adressen
versuche ich ja langsam zu steigern,
dadurch, dass unsere beiden
sexy Adressen weggefallen sind.
muss ich mich jetzt auf
sanktkirjan.vc berufen,
wo du mich immer noch erreichen kannst.
Stimmt, so eine habe ich auch irgendwie.
Ich glaube, Sankt Hendrik habe ich auch.
Aber ich hätte echt gerne irgendwas
at tld, das ist halt einfach nur mega cool,
wenn du direkt auf der tld in der E-Mail-Adresse hängst.
Auf jeden Fall, das ist ziemlich geil.
Ich hatte das mal gerade nachgeguckt,
ich habe eine schöne Seite gefunden, die hieß
standards.rest,
wo über unterschiedliche
REST-API-Standards
eine schöne Sammlung besteht und ich habe mir gedacht,
Punkt Rest, wer hat denn
so eine Top-Level-Domain
und wenn du nicht
Top-Level-Domain Punkt
eingeben kannst, was bei der nicht funktioniert,
funktioniert auch immer, also häufig
Nick Punkt, diese
und
Rest ist tatsächlich für
Restaurants, das ist
genau, da hast du lauter so
Gabel, Messer und Kochmützen
Symbole und
es ist also quasi wie Bar
bloß für was zu essen.
Ach so, und
haben wir auch eine schöne Karte dahinter,
dass das Rest halt
das Kürzel,
der Teil des Wortes Restaurant in diversen
Sprachen ist, der halt gleich ist. Und der Rest ist
halt unterschiedlich.
Ah, interessant.
Restaurante, Restaurant,
Restaurant, wie auch immer.
Restauranas, Restaurant.
Witzig.
Also wir könnten zum Beispiel die API für akronomisierbar
könnten wir auf akronomisier.rest packen.
Die API für akronomisierbar.
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Also auf jeden Fall eine schöne Sache,
um sich irgendwie APIs für seine Services zu registrieren.
Machst irgendwie.
Ja, also.rest ist bietet sich an dafür.
Da haben wir einen guten Plusgriff gemacht.
Also es gibt noch kein.graphql,
aber rest ist eh viel besser.
Egal.
Ja, ist ja eh viel cooler,
wenn du einfach wie Google
einfach deine Firmennamen als TLD registrierst.
Schon sehr sexy.
Auf jeden Fall. Schade, das ist sexy.
Aber Google.
löst nicht auf.
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn, Google?
Ernsthaft? Aber Google hat doch viele Sachen mit
gu.gle.
Aber warum löst Google
nicht auf auf eine weiße Weiterleitung zu
google.com oder so? Du kannst auf jeden Fall auf
gu.gle gehen. Das ist schon
ein bisschen armselig, Google, muss ich sagen.
Gut.
Ich muss
sagen, ich vermisse auch, ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich bei manchen Leuten
auf den Bildschirm gucke und die
einen neuen Tab aufmachen und da gibt es ja
dieses Picture of the Day
auf der Google Startseite,
was teilweise immer ziemlich liebevoll gemacht ist.
Das vermisse ich
irgendwie, weil ich nie auf Google gehe.
Meine neuen
Tabs sind immer leer, immer.
Das auch, aber benutzt du
Google als Hauptsuchmaschine?
Ich nutze nur noch DuckDuckGo.
Genau.
Ente-entelos.de
Ja, ddg.gg
Nee, entelos.de
entelos.de
tatsächlich.
Leitet auch weiter.
Oh mein Gott.
Ja, liebe Zuhörer, wir sind übrigens nicht unter uns gehören.
Liebe Zuhörer, schicken uns doch
eure lieblingslustigen Domains
zu irgendwelchen Seiten, wo ihr euch denkt,
Mensch, die TLDs sind geil.
Da können wir mal eine Sammlung.
Poop.bike ist mein Favorit.
Punktbike?
Nein, Poop.bike.
P-O-O-P.bike.
So eine herrliche, schöne Seite.
von einem Bike mit Poop
und dem Satz
Why did I buy this domain?
Okay.
Ich kann noch einen Screensaver in den Topf werfen.
Es gibt nämlich
bouncingdvdlogo.com
Oh, das ist genau so, was man denkt, oder?
Genau.
Ich habe es schon in die Show Notes geschmissen.
Perfekt.
Und, trifft es die Ecke?
Das geht nicht bis zum Rand.
Das prallt vorher ab.
Das hat irgendeinen Margin.
Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Was ist denn das für ein Müll?
Kannst du gleich mal gucken, wo der Code dazu ist.
Kannst du ein Pull-Request schicken.
Das erinnert mich direkt an die Serie
The Office, an diese eine Folge, wo sie da sitzen
und Michael zujubeln.
Also denkt er, aber tatsächlich
jubeln sie dem Fernseher hinter ihm zu,
weil sie denken, das Logo geht so fast in die Ecke.
Also, na dann doch nicht.
Naja, das ist jetzt hier ein anderes Seitenverhältnis.
Das Seitenverhältnis hängt davon ab, wie groß du dein Fenster
gezogen hast.
Das geht doch mit CSS
auch unordentlich.
Ja. Das ist doch hier
dynamisch. Das ist doch kein Video, oder?
Das ist doch kein Video. Das ist dynamisch.
Hoffe ich auch.
Was soll das denn?
Egal.
Armselig.
Gut.
Was haben wir denn noch?
Ich habe gesehen, dass ICQ
neu gelauncht ist. Die haben jetzt versucht,
mit auf den Bandwagon der
aktuell relevanten
Remote-Software, wir sind wieder beim Scheiß-Thema.
ICQ gehört nicht mehr
dieser israelischen Bude, sondern
die sind jetzt irgendwie komplett russisch geworden,
oder? Ich dachte, die waren vorher komplett
russisch. Waren die vorher komplett russisch?
Ich dachte, das wäre mal so eine israelische Bude gewesen.
Vielleicht hätten wir die History nachschlagen können,
habe ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, dass
das früher mal russisch war und
jetzt vielleicht wieder ist. Also ich würde darauf
tippen, dass es jetzt wieder so ist, weil du hast ja auch
die Bot-RP-Dokumentation gesehen.
Genau, genau. Also was ist
Das neue ICQ ist vornehmlich eine Handy-App
und es gibt eine Desktop-App. Hast du die schon ausprobiert?
Ist die irgendwie auch bloß ein Elektron?
Desktop-App habe ich nicht probiert.
Ich habe nur die Handy-App schon seit ein paar Monaten
jetzt wieder installiert, weil wir so kurz mal
gemerkt haben, dass es ganz witzig war
früher, haben alle an unsere Nummern erinnert.
Schreibt mir, 44834...
Ich dachte, die Nummern sind alle verfallen.
Teilweise.
Manche Leute können sich nicht mehr anmelden, aber
meine Nummer ist mein Username anscheinend.
Also 448341189.
Schreibt mir.
Und meine Nummer habe ich auch noch im Kopf, wenn ich sie wirklich am Stück durchsage, kriege ich sie noch zusammen, weil die irgendwie so Muscle Memory ist. Aber ich kann mich glaube ich nicht einloggen, weil ich das Passwort definitiv nicht mehr weiß und ich auch garantiert die E-Mail-Adresse, mit der ich mich da registriert habe, nicht mehr verwende.
Weil es so zu Zeiten war, da bin ich von
von GMX zu Web.de oder
andersrum zu Freenet gewechselt,
als, das ist ja
20 Jahre her.
Was waren das?
Das war das ICQ-Geräusch.
Dreh der
die Blitzende Seite und macht so ein Echo-Geräusch.
Und du hast es jetzt also schon ausprobiert,
ich skäuche hier bloß gerade so ein bisschen durch die Bilder durch.
Ich habe die Handy-App ausprobiert
und es fühlt sich, also die haben das Design ein bisschen
geupdatet und es ist jetzt,
Es fühlt sich an wie ein modernerer Messenger, aber irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Brand ist halt tot. Ich weiß nicht, wie man sowas wieder retten oder ob man es retten soll.
Also was mir bei den aktuellen Messenger wirklich auch meistens fehlt, was ich auch jetzt in letzter Zeit dadurch, dass ich das, dadurch, dass wir alle auch immer das machen bei Slack ein bisschen vermisse, ist wirklich Presence und Status, sowas, was die meisten Sachen abgeschafft haben, weil du eh irgendwann drauf guckst und nicht unbedingt wissen musst, in welchem Zustand jemand gerade ist, aber bei, gerade bei Sachen, wo ich den ganzen Tag drin bin und den ganzen Tag jederzeit mit irgendjemandem reden möchte, wie zum Beispiel bei Slack auf Arbeit.
Bei Slack kannst du dir einen Status stellen, aber der geht nicht automatisch nach 20 Minuten, wenn du nicht tippst, in den AFK-Modus.
Aber du siehst ja an dem kleinen grünen Bobbel in der Seitenleiste, ob die Person gerade online ist oder nicht.
Du siehst, ob die Person online ist, aber meistens sind sie ja immer online.
Online heißt, achso, weil der Rechner läuft, okay.
Genau, du kannst nicht, also du kannst einstellen, genau, also du kannst es bei Slack rudimentär machen.
Bei Slack hast du auch noch irgendwie eine witzige Outlook-Integration, dass du sagen kannst, er weiß, dass ich gerade in einem Meeting bin. Wenn ich also gerade ein Meeting gescheduled habe, habe ich bei Slack irgendwie so einen roten Punkt, dass jeder andere weiß, dass ich in einem Meeting bin. Das geht.
Aber es geht zum Beispiel nicht, wenn ich irgendwie jetzt in der Mittagspause nicht mehr am Computer sitze, automatisch in den Way-From-Keyboard-Modus oder sowas.
Vielleicht gibt es da eine Erweiterung, ich weiß nicht.
Wie gesagt, Slack hat das rudimentär, aber viele andere Messenger haben das halt nicht und auch aus gutem Grund nicht.
Aber es wäre zum Beispiel für ICQ, da war das ja so, dass du dieses historische schmale Fenster hattest, wo du einfach deinen Roster mit deinen anderen Participants gesehen hast,
wo du dann wusstest, der ist gerade
DND
oder Away oder
da gab es doch sogar
Happy to Talk oder sowas, da gab es irgendwie
Ja, aber damals hat man sich ja auch mit Schulfreunden
verabredet, heute 20 Uhr
im ICQ, weil nicht jeder
online nur mal zu Hause war und weil es keine Handys
gab, hatte man ja feste Online-Zeiten
beziehungsweise man hat halt den Rechner eingeschaltet
so wie du auch im IRC-Room halt da bist
oder nicht da, bis auf die Leute, die mit dem Bouncer
halt immer da sind, aber dann halt physisch
nicht da und halt den Namen von Afghanen sind
verschiedenen Modi, das zu benutzen.
Ich sag ja nur, das ist einer von den
eines von den charakterisierenden
Features von ICQ im Gegensatz zu
Signal oder WhatsApp gewesen.
Momentan sieht diese App hier aus, als wäre sie
einfach bloß ein neues Telegram.
Das erinnert mich zumindest ein bisschen dran.
Weil ich gerade auch sagen wollte, Telegram,
Apple hat den Online-Status auf jeden Fall.
Weil sie halt auch
davon ausgehen, dass die meisten Leute es über
Mobil nutzen. Du siehst halt, ob die Person gerade
den Client offen hat. Kannst du deaktivieren
als Nutzer? Also finde ich eine
gute UX eigentlich, dass du das deaktivieren kannst.
Du kannst aber auch deinen Online-Status
broadcasten und dann sehen Leute, mit denen du schreibst,
dass du gerade physisch diesen Chat offen hast
oder im Client aktiv bist.
Matrix zum Beispiel hat auch das Konzept
von Presence. Das gibt's ja wohl. Das muss aber
auch dein Home-Server explizit unterstützen.
Wollte grad sagen, das kenne ich nicht.
Also Matrix.org hat das aktiv.
Aha, aber ich...
Da siehst du in Riot auch, ob die Leute gerade
online sind. Aber da mein Server zum Beispiel das
daim nicht checkt, wirst du das bei mir, glaube ich,
nicht sehen. Stimmt, da sehe ich das irgendwie.
Ja, hast recht.
Du mit deinem eigenen Server.
Das ist auch mein eigener privater Server,
da ist niemand anders drauf.
Ich will ja hier nicht anderen Leuten irgendwie
uptimen, bereitstellen. Ich hoffe ja echt,
dass ich irgendwann so etabliert, dass ich hier
irgendwie Geld hinwerfen kann für Hosting
auf meiner Domain, genauso wie ich es mit E-Mail mache.
Naja, also das,
ich hoffe eigentlich, dass das kommt. Mein E-Mail-Anbieter
macht das, dementsprechend habe ich
witzigerweise... Dein E-Mail-Anbieter macht
Matrix? Nein, aber
mein Jabber-Account ist über meinen E-Mail-Anbieter.
Stimmt, das hatte meinen E-Mail-Anbieter
auch, das haben sie gestandtet vor ein paar Jahren,
da war ich super traurig. Genau,
mittlerweile könnte es fast so sein, dass du mal fragen kannst,
ob die nicht irgendwann
über deine Domain, aber ich weiß nicht, wie gut
funktionieren, können diese
Home-Server, können die Multi-Domain-Support,
weil theoretisch wäre es ja für
den E-Mail-Anbieter dann interessant,
einen Server hinzustellen und dann zu managen,
okay, es gibt, ich bin der Matrix-Server
für diese 35.000
Domains aller meiner Kunden.
Prinzipiell, ja.
Synapse kann das nicht,
aber Synapse ist ja auch nur einer,
also ist ja aktuell die einzige
wirklich komplett funktionssüchtige
Implementierung eines Matrix Home Servers,
aber als gibt es da andere.
Gibt es sowas wie
Load Balancer oder
Reverse Proxys für Matrix, dass du
sagen kannst, ich stelle mir einfach was davor,
was dann irgendwie die Domain simuliert
und dahinter ist es eigentlich wahrscheinlich, das ist ja auch
bloß eine REST API insgesamt,
An sich kannst du da bestehendes Tooling nutzen,
aber Synapse, wie gesagt, kommt nicht damit klar,
dass verschiedene User mit verschiedenen Matrix-IDs
darum hantieren können auf dem selben Server.
Aber ich meine, also ein Zukunftsaspekt,
den die Matrix-Leute ja mit ein bisschen pushen,
das haben wir ja vor kurzem gedemot auf der Forstam,
dass du Synapse für, nee, Dendrite,
die Go-Implementierung für Wasm baust.
Bei Dendrite, das klingt immer wie Dendroff, ganz ehrlich.
Ich denke irgendwas im Zahnarzt-Kontext
immer da bei Dendrite.
Könnte auch eine Zahnpasta sein.
Aber die haben das Ding
für Wathom gebaut und
in den Client integriert.
Stimmt. Sodass du in deinem Client
deinen Homeserver mit hast und quasi so richtig
Peer-to-Peer, jeder Client ist sein eigener Homeserver.
Was eine witzige Idee ist.
Stimmt.
Das war ganz schön krass.
Aber ansonsten gibt es ja noch,
gerade hier, wenn wir beim Thema Matrix-Homeserver sind,
auch ein paar Nachrichten. Wir hatten ja schon mal über
Rooma gesprochen vor einer Weile.
Das war dieser Rust-Homeserver,
dieses Rust-Matrix-Homeserver-Projekt.
Der ziemlich lange die Arbeit pausiert hatte,
weil er einfach warten wollte, bis
sich sehr viel
Protokollarbeit etwas beruhigt.
Die haben halt pausiert. Die haben an dem Homeserver
nicht weitergearbeitet, aber die haben sehr wohl
die Crates für diverses Tooling
und vor allem die Client-Crates haben sie weitergebaut.
Stimmt, die API-Client-Crates haben sich
weiterentwickelt und wurden in diversen
Clients weiterverwendet.
Und jetzt gibt es aber irgendwie Nachrichten
von dem Homeserver selber, oder wie?
Genau, also Rooma selber
hat jetzt angekündigt, dass der Homeserver eingestellt ist.
Das Rooma-Projekt ist damit
tot. Sehr sad.
Aber klassisch
Rooma is dead, Long live
nicht Rooma, sondern ein sehr
ähnliches Projekt. Das hat
gewisser Timo Kösters entwickelt das gerade
weiter. Das heißt, es ist ein eigenes Homeserver-Projekt
auf RAS-Basis auf den Rooma-Creatment
aufbauen, namens Conduit.
Das ist nicht einfach ein Fork
oder eine Weiterentwicklung, sondern der baut was von vorne
mit den gleichen Crates?
Das ist komplett eine Neuimplementierung.
Sorry, wie heißt das?
Conduit.
Cool.
Conduit.rs.
Die Rust TLD.
Es ist sehr cool,
vor allem, weil es sehr schnell voranschreitet.
Ich vermute auch, weil die
UMA-Bibliotheken auch ziemlich sauber sind.
Aktuell macht er, glaube ich, sogar schon alles
bis auf Federation.
Also es ist schon ein echt vorangeschrittenes Projekt
bei 50 Commits im Git-Repo.
Naja, wenn du die ganzen Sachen aus den Crates bereits verwenden kannst,
ist das ja ganz gut.
Also ich glaube, das baut auf den Huma-Crates auf,
wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Ich musste da auch nochmal reinschauen, um das zu verifizieren.
Aber auf jeden Fall sehr cool
und es freut mich, noch mehr performantere Upcoming-Homesolver zu sehen.
Also ich hoste ja mein eigenes Synapse
und ich würde so, so gerne auf Dendrite
oder possibly Conduit dann umsteigen,
weil Synapse einfach so ressourcenfressend ist.
Obwohl ich mir bei Python-basierten Services
auch die Frage stelle,
es gibt ja Twisted.
Benutzt Synapse dann Twisted?
Weißt du das?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich meine nicht.
Twisted ist ja eigentlich so was wie LibUV,
so eine krasse C-basierte Networking-Lib,
die irgendwie auch noch asynchron ist,
dass man eigentlich theoretisch damit
auch ziemlich performante Python-Services,
also relativ performante Python-Services bauen könnte.
Aber es bleibt halt trotzdem Python.
Ich meine, es kann ja auch ein bisschen performanter werden,
aber du hast halt trotzdem, finde ich,
für so eine Größe der Anwendung unsichere Software.
Also ich meine, du kannst jetzt mit Python nicht
die typischen Safety-Probleme, die du auf anderen Sprachen kennst,
aber du hast halt trotzdem eine sehr dynamische Sprache,
die dir ziemlich viele Freiheiten lässt.
Du musst halt ziemlich defensiv arbeiten,
um wirklich gute Python-Software zu schreiben.
Und du hast halt das Problem, dass es halt als Python läuft.
Du kannst es nicht zu irgendwas anderem auf einer anderen Plattform
crosscompilen und da halt eine Binary hinlegen.
Es gibt schon für Python gibt es auch Packager,
wo du sagen kannst, das machen ja viele,
die Desktop-Python-Software ausliefern.
Da kriegst du dann auch eine gepackagte Binary,
wo quasi das passende Python selber mit drin ist.
Aber es bleibt halt Python.
Tja.
Ich kenne mich auch nicht gut aus,
was diese CPython-Ansätze angeht und andere.
Da gibt es eine ganze Reihe von Sachen.
Da bin ich nicht wirklich versiert.
Es gibt PyPy, das ist Python in Python.
What?
Es gibt einen Python-Interpreter,
der in Python geschrieben ist und der ist mitunter
schneller als der C-Python-Interpreter.
Ah, sehr geil.
Auf jeden Fall.
Da können wir gerne mal, wenn ihr Hörer
da mehr Ahnung habt, kommt doch mal in den Akonomisierbar-Raum
auf unseren Matrix
und erzählt uns bitte mal,
was es da so gibt und wie es
in der Python-Entwicklung ausschaut und warum das immer noch
Python 2 ist.
Was hatte ich da gesehen?
Es gibt ein Crate, wo du gerade von Rust redest.
Und das war, war das diese Woche in This Week in Python?
Habe ich das gesagt?
Warum in This Week in Python?
This Week in Rust meine ich.
Ach so, okay.
Es gibt ein Inline-Python für Rust.
Das heißt tatsächlich einfach Inline-Python.
Genau, da hast du ein Makro.
Das heißt Python, Ausrufezeichen.
Dann machst du einen Block.
Und das sind die letzten geschweiften Klammern,
die du dann da siehst. Die nächste geschweifte Klammer ist dann
wieder, wie das Makro zugeht
und da drin kannst du dann Python schreiben.
Aber da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, dass du ja dann in dem Makro
andere Indentation und Whitespace
und also anderen Whitespace brauchst.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Makro
wirklich Whitespace-Preserving
ist, aber ich glaube,
ja, denn es ist so ein Prog-Makro
und das Prog-Makro kriegt einfach bloß den gesamten
Codestring von dem, was du da
reinkriegst und kann dann damit pausen und machen,
was es will. Das ist schon geil
irgendwo. Das ist schon...
diese ganzen fancy Makros
für Rust sind halt schon ein mega cooles
Feature, gerade vor allem diese ganzen Makros, die einfach
anderen Code embedden.
Finde ich super cool.
Auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe ja, ich habe neulich
mal wieder einen
Vortrag gehalten und zwar
war ich bei der C++ User Group
Dresden, beziehungsweise
die C++ User Group Dresden war bei mir,
denn ich habe es von diesem
Platz an diesem Schreibtisch auf diesem Stuhl gehalten
und
das waren
das erste Online-Meetup.
Du kannst es auf YouTube finden. Ich kann den Link
ja mal, wenn du es unbedingt sehen willst, noch in die Shownotes
schmeißen.
Ich finde, das haben wir noch gar nicht thematisiert
oder hatten wir das letzte Mal vielleicht.
Was ich gerade geil finde, ist, dass dadurch,
dass alle Meetups irgendwie momentan
online sind, kannst du auch zu Meetups gehen, die gar nicht in deiner Stadt
sind. Das ist ein echten Feature.
Ich war schon bei Berliner Rust-Meetups.
Bei dem Dresdner
C++-Meetup waren relativ viele Leute,
die gar nicht aus Dresden kommen.
Einer war da aus Karlsruhe, der gesagt hat, ah ja, ich habe gehört, dass ihr so einen Vortrag macht. Ich halte morgen auf meinem C++-Meetup einen Vortrag über Rust. Deswegen wollte ich mir mal aneben, was du heute so erzählst.
Wie cool. Vielleicht kann man das ja zum Teil auch beibehalten, nachdem der ganze Corona-Fu vorbei ist. Also nicht unbedingt die Home-Forenses in der Größe.
Also wir haben definitiv die C++ Meetups, wenn sie bei uns in der Firma zu Gast waren, haben wir online gestellt, das wir direkt auf Twitter veröffentlicht haben hier.
Joint dieses Meeting und dann könnt ihr euch, das könnt ihr live an dem Meetup teilnehmen.
Sehr cool.
Das macht es dann auch ohne weiteres möglich, dass du das mal eben dann aufzeichnest.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool.
Finde ich, sollte man häufiger machen.
Zumindest ich habe da einen kleinen Vortrag gehalten.
Wie bin ich da eigentlich dazu hingekommen?
Bei was waren wir jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
äh
Rust
Macros, nee, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Fuck, ich hab den Faden verloren.
Ich auch. Ich komm grad
nicht mehr drauf, wie wir da zu haben.
Wir waren bei Parm. Aber du hast auf jeden Fall dein,
erzähl mal, was du für einen Talk gehalten hast.
Ähm,
ja, und da hab ich einen Vortrag gehalten,
eigentlich einen relativ oberflächlichen
Introduction into Rust
for C++ Developers.
Das war jetzt auch kein, ich hab am Anfang auch
Disclaimer gemacht, this is not a tutorial.
You do not need to have any prior Rust knowledge.
Und dann habe ich einfach mal so ein bisschen Mechanismen und Syntaxen nebeneinander gehalten.
Was gibt es hier, was gibt es dort nicht?
Wie macht man dies und jenes und wie sieht das aus?
Also wirklich relativ oberflächlich.
Der Typ, der dann da zu Gast war und gesagt hat, ich halte morgen einen ähnlichen Vortrag, hat gemeint, ja, ich gehe viel mehr ins Detail.
Na gut, okay, dann ist ja gut, dass du das machst.
Danke
so, aber
genau, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ist
eigentlich cool, dass man, dass diese ganzen
Meetups jetzt auch online funktionieren und man auch
in anderen Städten zu Meetups gehen kann
deswegen
gibt es irgendwelche Swift Meetups, zu denen du gehst
oder Matrix Meetups
oder tatsächlich nicht
leider, aber
was jetzt letzte Woche war, war
die D-Walk
was man ja, es ist schon eher mehr eine
Home for Rents als ein Meetup gewesen.
Das war das digital verteilte Online-Chaos.
Das war so eine Art
Mini-Chaos-Meetup-
Congress-Dingens,
wo alle daheim halt
saßen, weil wir halt
das Coolste, was im Chaos-Umfeld existiert,
ist die mega geile Infrastruktur
oder eins der
coolsten Dinge, die wir haben und
die können wir halt auch so nutzen, wenn wir alle daheim
sitzen.
Divock stand für was nochmal?
digital verteiltes Online-Chaos
oder, wenn du es rückwärts liest,
Covid.
Das war aber quasi der Ersatz
für die Easter Hack, oder?
Ich glaube fast.
So stand es glaube ich nicht auf der Webseite, aber ich gehe
davon aus, weil die Easter Hack
ja jetzt wegfällt.
Ja, Ostern ist ja auch vorbei, du spierst.
Das sowieso, also zeitlich
wäre es jetzt eh weg.
Cool, was gab es da
für Vorträge? Ich habe es leider gar nicht mitbekommen.
Der Fahrplan ist natürlich noch online, kann man mal reinschauen.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen mal kurz reingeschaut,
aber ich habe nur einen Vortrag länger angeschaut
und das war der Quo Vadis Gesichtserkennung von Starbuck am Sonntag.
War das letzte Woche? Ja, letzte Woche.
Aber was ich auch krass war,
also manche Leute saßen halt so daheim vor ihrer Kamera,
haben ihre Slide noch vom Screen geshared
und dann kommt Starbuck daher und hat so ein Profi-Streamer-Setup,
wo er so vor einem Greenscreen sitzt,
vor einem fancy Hintergrund mit der Slide
schon neben ihnen auf demselben Bildschirm
gepackt. Das war
technisch sehr geil.
Das war cool.
Das müsste ich fast nochmal raussuchen. Was mich
geflasht hatte, war, ich hatte beim letzten Mal schon
erzählt, dass ich bei diesem
bei dieser Oxidize 1K war,
bei dieser ziemlich am Anfang
von dem Lockdown organisierten
Rust Embedded Konferenz
und da waren, das war
wirklich relativ schnell zusammengecleared, da hatten
alle bloß so Vorträge von so
15, 20 Minuten.
Also zusammengekleert ist jetzt ein bisschen, stellt es mit
Schatten, das war schon eine gute Veranstaltung.
Es war im Endeffekt eine einabendliche
Veranstaltung.
Und dann waren zwischen den Talks waren immer
Musikpausen von einem.
Ich suche das mal raus. Das war eigentlich auch
ziemlich geil. Das war, der Typ hatte,
das war live, das war so eine Live-Coding-
Musikgeschichte. Das heißt, du
hast ihn gesehen in dem Raum, aber
das kam richtig Club-Atmosphäre
eigentlich rüber. Du hattest Kameras mal von
vorne, mal von hinten, hat irgendwie den Raum
gefilmt. Oben drüber, über
diesen Kamerafeed hatte er aber auch immer halb
sein Code
gelegt, wo du gesehen hast, Wasser
gehackt hat. Gleichzeitig noch irgendwelche
Audiovisualisierungen
oben drüber und dann hat er
noch bunte Disco-Lichter überall in dem
Raum gehabt. Wie cool ist das denn? Das war übelst geil.
Das suche ich nochmal raus. Das sah ziemlich geil aus.
Und vor allem, es war Live-Coding.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob dir Live-Coding
was sagt, aber du siehst quasi jemand,
wie er einen Sequencer
live hinschreibt. Jede Zeile
irgendwie einen Sound und dann
kannst du irgendwie mit
Parametern irgendwie die Samples
modifizieren und dann
zum Schluss fadest du einen Song aus, indem du
Zeile für Zeile wieder auskommentierst und dann
hört das Lied einfach auf. Das ist eine ziemlich
geile Sache gewesen. Das ist, glaube ich, alles
Ruby gewesen. Dann schreibt dann da Ruby hin
und es passiert Musik.
Und der hatte auch so eine geile Videoinstallation.
Da haben sie immer, das war auch ein Zoom,
da haben sie irgendwie dann zu ihm hingeschalten und dann
hast du sein Video gesehen und den hat er dann
live irgendwie mit so ein bisschen
Video-Studio-Software hin und her geschalten
und da hast du immer mal ein anderes Perspektive gehabt.
Ziemlich fett.
Okay, das ist schon mega fancy.
Du musst auf jeden Fall die Link mal
in die Show noch reinpacken.
Die Aufzeichnungen sind wahrscheinlich noch auf
YouTube.
Erzähl doch mal bitte, sorry, ich habe dich unterbrochen,
zur D-Wog noch ein bisschen weiter.
Ach so, die Talks sind alle auf
media.ccc.de natürlich auch mit
aufgenommen und da kann man
auf jeden Fall mal reinschauen.
Die von Starbuck kann ich empfehlen, der war ganz nett.
Ich habe jetzt aber den Kontext auch ein bisschen verloren,
um was es dann im Detail nochmal alles ging.
Also es ging um, was ist der aktuelle Stand zur Gesichtserkennung
und was wird so gemacht?
Und was auch so, also vor allem auch von dem technischen
als auch gesellschaftlichen Aspekt.
Aber es gibt auch, wie gesagt, ein paar andere weitere Vorträge.
Die Lightning Talks wollte ich mir noch anschauen.
Die sind vielleicht ja auch ganz witzig,
so als jeder erzählt von daheim.
Und es sind natürlich ein paar,
wenn von den Leuten, die von daheim reden,
so ein paar Nerd-Wohnzimmer, was auch ganz witzig ist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie dir das geht.
Hast du tatsächlich Videokonferenzen
mit deinen Kollegen?
Ja, sehr gemütlich.
Achtest du darauf, was im Raum hinter dir zu sehen ist
und im Bild ist?
Ich versuche normalerweise eine Katze mit ins Bild zu holen.
Ach, du versuchst explizit eine Katze mit ins Bild zu holen?
Das freut meine Kollegen immer.
Aber ansonsten versuche ich einfach
nicht zu zeigen, dass ich
keine Hose trage oder so, wenn du darauf hinaus möchtest.
Also ich versuche schon das Sofa, was mir hinter mir im Bild zu sehen ist, immer ein bisschen gerade zu rücken, dass es ein bisschen ordentlich aussieht.
Manchmal stelle ich noch bewusst eine Gitarre ins Bild oder so.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Da ist ja jemand unterwegs, das ist ja sehr das Wohnzimmer-Styling.
Ja, ich meine, gerade bei der Konferenz, bei der C++-Mittag, da hast du jetzt eine Stunde Bild aus meinem Wohnzimmer quasi da auf YouTube.
Das ist schon ein bisschen...
Steht deswegen die Gitarre so schräg hinter dir?
Explizit deswegen?
Nee, die steht auch, weil ich, das ist ja
mein Arbeitsumfeld, in dem ich mich hier bewege
und wenn ich Bock habe, dann gehe ich mal nach hinten
und greife nach diesem Instrument und dann spiele ich halt
mal eine Runde so vor mich hin.
Mir fällt auch gerade auf, dass ich auf der
Gitarre eigentlich immer noch oben am Kopf so ein
Post-It habe,
wo drauf steht, was ich unbedingt noch machen wollte,
wenn ich die das nächste Mal in die Hand
nehme und ich habe sie offenbar doch
ein, zwei Tage nicht in die Hand genommen,
fällt mir gerade auf. Ich habe dir mal den Link
zu der Oxidize
1K in YouTube
in den Chat geschrieben.
Ich poste es auch gleich.
Ich habe das schon aufgemacht. Das ist echt ein geiles Setting.
So mit Kamera von schräg hinten.
Ich habe es gerade ohne Ton gehört, weil
logischerweise gerade aufnehmen.
Der Typ wippt so mit der Musik mit. Du siehst ihn live tippen
mit diesem Overlay von dem Code und diese
Licht-Aposphäre. Das ist echt super, super
cool. Auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall.
Lass uns doch mal
noch in unseren Themen ein bisschen weitergehen.
Also Divock hast du gesagt, kann man sich angucken, kannst nur einen Talk wirklich empfehlen, weil du die anderen auch noch nicht gekauft hast?
Ja genau, also nicht, weil ich den Rest nicht empfehlen kann, sondern weil ich nur diesen einen wirklich erlebt habe.
Nice, dann kann ich mir die vielleicht auch nochmal angucken.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, aber ich sage mir auch immer nach dem Kongress zum Beispiel,
ach den und den und den Talk könnte ich mir eigentlich dann auch hinterher noch online angucken.
Und dann mache ich es ehrlich gesagt ziemlich häufig einfach nicht.
Ich habe so eine Liste gesammelt aus allen Kongressen, wo ich bisher war.
die ist quasi append-only,
da geht nichts von weg.
Die eternal backlog.
50, 60 Talks, genau.
Und genauso mit meiner Reading-List.
Ich habe so 20.000 Links, die ich mir noch anschauen möchte.
Irgendwann archiviere ich die über ein Pinboard
und denke mir so, ja, ja, jetzt,
dann schaust du da wirklich mal rein.
Ich habe mir auch schon Tools geschrieben,
die über die Pinboard-API einen random Link rausholen
und den einfach in Safari öffnen.
Aber ich ist einfach tot.
Also die werden da bleiben, bis ich sterbe.
Für immer.
Und auch lange danach noch wahrscheinlich.
Naja, wahrscheinlich nicht so lange danach,
irgendwann wird einfach die Zivilisation zusammenbrechen.
Hattest du mir
den Podcast The Fall of Civilizations
empfohlen?
Nee, sag mir nichts. Kennst du den?
Nee. Du bist doch sonst so ein Waff für
so History-Podcasts.
Ja, meine Podcast-Cue ist gerade
aber ins Unermessliche gewachsen, weil ich keine
Commute mehr habe.
Ich habe einen Podcast zu empfehlen,
dass du den noch nicht kennst, der wird dir
garantiert gefallen und zwar heißt der The Fall of
Civilizations.
Und der passt irgendwie
Erstaunlich gut in die aktuelle Zeit.
Auch.
Und der Typ ist Historiker und redet auch in so einer ruhigen und irgendwie bedächtlichen Stimme.
Das hat alles so einen gewissen, da kommt echt Atmosphäre auf bei.
Und da ist eine Folge ist, genau der, genau der.
Da ist aber die erste Folge ist The Fall of Roman Britain.
Denn der zweite ist The Bronze Age Collapse, The Mayan Collapse, The Greenland Vikings.
Und das ist alles immer so eine Zivilisation pro Folge,
die da zusammenbricht.
Oh, cooles Konzept.
Auf jeden Fall.
Also es ist ein ziemlich cooler Podcast, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe mir mal die erste Folge runtergeladen.
Auf meine List.
Also meine Podcast-Cue ist aktuell so unglaublich lang,
das ist so richtig zermürbend.
Du musst mal mehr spazieren gehen, Kian.
Ja, sollte ich.
Alleine.
Nee, ab morgen darfst du dich auch wieder mit Leuten,
eine theoretisch könnten wir beide uns morgen auch wieder treffen.
Ich gehöre nicht zu deinem Haushalt
und ab morgen darfst du wieder eine Person,
die nicht zu deinem Haushalt gehört, treffen.
Ich finde diese Lockerung so bekloppt, aber okay.
Ich meine, ich kann auch nur sprechen aus der Rolle,
aus dem von jemandem, dessen Existenz nicht gefährdet ist.
Wenn das anders aussieht, würde ich es vielleicht anders sehen,
aber ich gehe einfach nicht mit,
dass Schulen geöffnet werden sollen gerade.
Das ist...
Es ist ein Tick unverantwortlich,
aber auf der anderen Seite muss das Leben irgendwie
auf eine gewisse Art und Weise weitergehen. Das ist ein schmaler
Grad und ich bin froh, dass ich die Entscheidung nicht treffen muss.
Das ist natürlich
auch wahr. Also ja, es ist gut, dass
das nicht auf meinen Schulden erlastet. Respekt vor denen,
die sich damit auseinandersetzen müssen.
Das stimmt.
Nächstes Thema. Ich habe hier noch ein Tweet mit
auf die Liste gepackt. Vorhin hatte ich das
Wasm ja schon mal angesprochen. Das ist einfach nur ein kurzer
Tweet, weil ich es sehr cool fand.
Nämlich haben die Leute im iWork-Team
bei Apple, also die
Apples Office Suite Maintain, Pages, Numbers
und Keynote, die haben
ja auch Web-Versionen davon auf iCloud.com
und haben wohl
teilweise den Code einfach jetzt
recyceln können und haben eine Toolchain, um
teilweise den Objective-C-Code von
iWork-Apps
Was sind iWork-Apps?
Also diese
MacOS-Desktop-Apps, die in Objective-C
hauptsächlich geschrieben sind, haben sie jetzt
teilweise zu Wasm-Compiled
und denselben Code
auf der Webseite am Laufen, was ich mega
cool finde.
Da gibt es auch nicht viele Details zu, ist ja auch interner von Apple und Software, zu denen Apple nichts preisgibt, aber die kann man halt nutzen und die Versionen auf iCloud.com sind auch echt nicht schlecht, aber die kannst du natürlich auch, glaube ich, nur benutzen mit einer Apple-ID, aber die ist ja kostenlos, aber gut.
Und was für Apps sind das dann mit unter?
Also Pages, Numbers und Keynote, die Äquivalente für Textverarbeitung, Tabellenkalkulation und Präsentationssoftware.
Du kannst auf iCloud, kannst du jetzt Keynote benutzen?
Das kannst du schon länger, aber die haben
die jetzt ein bisschen,
die haben vorher,
die waren das vermutlich,
gehe ich mal davon aus, komplett eigenständig
entwickelte Web-Apps und jetzt
sind die halt teilweise derselbe Code wie die
Desktop-Apps. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein
Vorschritt oder ein Rückschritt ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Du als WhatsApp-Fanboy
siehst das als Rückschritt?
Auf den Punkt habe ich
von vornherein hingewiesen, dass es eigentlich
nicht dazu gedacht ist, dass du irgendwie
alten Desktop-Code ins Web schiebst.
exakt das.
Vor allem finde ich das geil, weil seit
Jahren kommen diese ganzen
Webentwickler daher und müllen
Desktop-Plattformen mit Webfoo zu.
Und jetzt können wir endlich zurückschlagen und
das Web zumüllen mit Desktopfoo.
Ab 45 wird zurückgecodet.
Oh Mann.
Ich will das Webseiten
richtig lahm werden, weil es komplette
Desktop-Anwendungen sind. Genau das brauchen
wir jetzt. Webseiten, wo 35
unterschiedliche Programmiersprachen
dran laufen. Dann kann ich als nativer
endlich Webfuh machen.
Diese Diskussion geht mir auf den Keks.
Dieses Nativ versus Web.
Ich mache dieses Fass jetzt nicht auf,
aber ich habe mich von dem Begriff Nativ
vor einigen Monaten verabschiedet
und ich nenne Sachen nicht mehr Nativ,
weil es einfach fehlleitend ist.
Das weigere ich mich zu akzeptieren.
Ich habe mich damals so aufgeregt als Postman,
diese Rest-Test-App da für APIs,
die eine Chrome-Packaged-App war,
eine Postman-Native-App rausgebracht habe,
was eine Elektron-App war.
Das hat mich so unglaublich angekotzt,
dass die sich so frech sind.
Doch, das ist genau der Troll, den ich machen würde.
Genau diesen Troll würde ich machen.
Also es gibt für mich, gibt es die Unterscheidung,
es gibt Web, es gibt Mobile und es gibt Desktop.
Und Native und nicht Native, diese Kategorien,
das sind doch bürgerliche Kategorien, ganz ehrlich.
Das gibt es nicht mehr.
Wunderschön.
Also gerade weil...
Zu einem gewissen Punkt, ja.
Genau, also ich meine,
Also wenn du was mit JavaScript in einem Browser machst,
das ist genauso native.
Das ist web-native.
Wenn du jetzt, wenn du sogenannten nativen Code,
also Objective-C oder C++ mit WebAssembly in den Browser schiebst,
ist das dann native?
Das ist erst recht nicht native.
Ja, aber der nächste Schritt ist ja dann diese,
also dass du deine Desktop-App nimmst,
dass du die durch Wasim jagst zu einer Web-App machst
und das wieder in den Elektron-Container zurückrappst.
Genau, das haben sie ja schon mit Windows 95 gemacht.
Was?
Achso, nee, ich meine, dass du dann halt noch einen Schritt weiter gehst
und das wieder rausziehst.
Also die Browser-Engine nutzt in einer Desktop-App,
um dadurch deine verpackte, verpackte, verpackte App
am Laufen zu halten.
Ich meine, im Endeffekt ist genau das,
was du mit Wasi, mit WebAssembly
außerhalb des Webs ja machen möchtest.
Du möchtest deinen Code irgendwie so bauen,
können, dass du quasi die Versprechen
von der Java-Runtime
heute nochmal neu
aufgeben kannst, dass du sagst, ich kann
in Objective-C, in C++,
in Rust, in C programmieren
und kriege Maschinencode raus,
der allerdings hinterher nicht direkt auf der CPU
läuft, sondern auf so einer
WebAssembly-Runtime wie
Wasma oder Lucet oder Wasmtime
oder was auch immer, damit du da
dann erstens
nicht mal fünfmal
umkompilieren musst für unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche Hardware-Plattformen wie ARM x86-64, x86-32 und so weiter und so fort. Und dass du vor allem nicht direkt auf der POSIX-Plattform läufst und jeden File-Händel anfassen darfst oder den gesamten Speicher vor dir hast oder aufs Netzwerk zugreifen kannst, obwohl du es nicht solltest. Das sind ja eigentlich die Sachen, die geil sind.
Also für mich sind es eigentlich zwei Aspekte hier. Du hast einmal die, du möchtest mit nativen Code in Anführungsstrichen, möchtest du bestmögliche Performance haben, die halt geht.
Du möchtest mit kompiliertem Code möglichst, nee. Ja, was ist jetzt nativ?
Ich möchte immer bestmögliche Performance haben, mit allem eigentlich. Und für die Dinge, wo es kritisch ist, wenn ich große Daten verarbeite und auch darauf warten muss, dass sie der Daten verarbeitet werden oder so, dann möchte ich jetzt natürlich, dass es so schnell wie möglich geht, logisch.
Aber das andere, was für mich so viel, also nicht unbedingt relevanter, aber was halt viel offensichtlicher noch ist, ist der Aspekt, dass die UI in Anführungsstrichen nativ ist. Sprich, die UI ist flott, die UI nutzt gewohnte Bausteine, die UI flackert nicht, wenn ich das Fenster resize, den ganzen Bullshit, den ich halt mit Webtechnologie auf dem Desktop habe. Und wenn sich das kaputt anfühlt, dann will ich das auch nicht nutzen.
Und das ist halt der Vorteil, den ich durch klassischerweise nativ betitelte Apps habe. Ich habe UI-Toolkits, die sauber funktionieren, die sich wie gute Citizens auf der Plattform anfühlen, die alle ähnlich ausschauen.
Gut, okay, das ist eine Art und Weise, wo du sagen kannst, nativ, ich benutze native UI-Komponenten. Aber sowas hast du ja zum Beispiel bei React Native auch. Und da hast du trotzdem JavaScript drin laufen. Ist das nativ? Ist das nativ?
ist das semi-nativ?
Ich würde es nicht als nativ bezeichnen,
semi-nativ ist ein schöner Begriff dafür,
also ich habe halt auch noch
nicht verstanden, das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
wie es eine React Native App schafft,
dass sie sich trotzdem, also dass du
die benutzen kannst und merkst, dass es eine
React Native App ist, weil eigentlich ist das doch
native UI. Was machen die noch anders,
dass sich das immer noch nicht richtig anfühlt?
Ob da jetzt JavaScript im Hintergrund läuft
und tatsächlich die
Business-Logik macht, das kann ich ja als Endnutzer
eigentlich nicht feststellen dürfen.
Das macht erstaunlicherweise, machen das auch schon
mehr Apps, als du denkst.
Machen die das nur durch Cross-Plattform?
Ich meine, weil die Cross-Plattformen
die Dinge bauen und nicht auf UI-Konzepte
achten. Also du kriegst
bei richtig vielen Apps, fühlst du wirklich,
ah ja, das ist eine Flutter-App, ah ja, das ist eine React-Native-App.
Das kriegst du direkt mit, ohne
dass du hier spezifisch auf
Elemente davon achten musst oder siehst,
weil die, ah, der Bildschirm ist gerade komplett rot geworden
mit der typischen Flutter-Debug-Meldung.
Da hat der Entwickler was verkackt und jetzt sehe ich, dass es eine Flutter-App ist.
Aber das ist ja, ich kriege das ja,
ich wette, es gibt Apps, die mich täuschen darin,
weil sie einfach gut entwickelt sind.
Aber bei so vielen merke ich das eben raus,
dass es nicht das ist, was ich erwarte und was ich will.
Und das finde ich blöd.
Also es ist ein ganz schönes Fass, was wir hier gerade aufmachen,
zumal ich selber auch nicht wirklich der Experte für UX-Entwicklung bin.
Aber du hast ja für, reden wir jetzt mal von,
das ist jetzt ein Feld, wo ich mich wirklich nicht auskenne,
macOS-Desktop.
Du hast ja unterschiedliche Varianten, wie du jetzt einen Button dahin rennen kannst. Du kannst entweder die, wie heißt es, bei Mac OS wirklich nativ, wie du es vor 20 Jahren schon gemacht hattest. Genau, du hättest Coco nutzen können.
Ja, vor 20 Jahren hieß es noch Aqua, aber jetzt ist Coco nativ.
Jetzt haben sie irgendwie noch Milchpulver und Kakaopulver reingekippt.
Und es heiß gemacht.
Du kannst irgendwie da mit Objective-C Code generieren,
aber wenn du zum Beispiel dein Widget-Code händisch schreiben,
bei Qt ist es so, dass du entweder mit C++-Code
deine Widgets ineinander schachtelst
und dann da gruseligen C++-Code mit Unclear Ownership schreibst.
Oder du hast irgendwie so eine Beschreibungs-XML-Sprache,
die dir entweder C++ generiert
Oder dann aber zum Schluss hast du trotzdem irgendwie irgendwas, was dir auf die gleiche Art und Weise deine Buttons zusammenbaut. Ob die das zur Runtime erst aus irgendeiner XML-Datei liest oder aus irgendeiner Datei liest und dann zusammenstückelt oder ob du irgendeine JavaScript-Runtime hast, die irgendwie aus ihrem internen Zustand dann wieder Calls an eine C-API macht oder eine Objective-C-API macht, um da wieder die gleichen Buttons ineinander zu schachteln.
ist ja dann trotzdem eine native UI.
Ist ja trotzdem die gleichen Chords,
um die Buttons ineinander zu schachteln, oder?
Na, nicht ganz.
Die nutzen ja inhärent andere Rendering-Techniken.
Es spricht ja nichts dagegen,
dass die theoretisch überpassende Bindings
exakt dieselben APIs ansprechen
und eine Cocoa-Oberfläche zeichnen.
Machen die aber nicht.
Eine Qt-App ist eine Qt-App.
Genau, also Qt ist nochmal ein extra Beispiel.
Qt ist einfach dafür bekannt,
dass die überall ihre eigenen Buttons malen.
Deswegen sind sie auch am portabelsten
und die kriegen es einfach hin mit Theming,
das möglichst nativ aussehen zu lassen,
dass deine Buttons auf Windows aussehen wie die anderen Windows-Buttons
und auf Mac aussehen wie die anderen Mac-Buttons.
Das kriegen die irgendwie hin.
Aber das sind jetzt nicht die nativen Buttons.
Aber React Native, woran siehst du eine React Native auf iOS an,
dass die in der React Native App ist?
Das Vollverhalten zum Beispiel ist komplett broken.
Das Momentum stimmt nicht.
die, du hast
hm,
das könnte an so Sachen liegen,
dass du zum Beispiel eine höhere Latenz hast,
weil das zwischendurch nochmal
Kontext-Switches zwischen der JavaScript-Runtime.
Das ist doch alles performant genug
dafür, das glaube ich nicht. Das ist
irgendwie der React Native Rendering Stack,
der irgendwie komischen Kram macht oder
keine Ahnung, ich blick's nicht.
Ich hab auch, wie gesagt, React Native nur für
zwei kurze Demos mal jemals benutzt, um mal
zu testen, wie die Toolchain funktioniert
und war sehr
unbegeistert davon und habe deswegen das nicht weiter
angefasst. Aber das ist nur meine
persönliche Meinung. Mit dem Stack kann man ja trotzdem gute
Apps bauen, aber
ich verstehe nicht, wo dieses kaputte Gefühl herkommt.
Also ich weiß nur,
dass es sich komisch anfühlt. Das ist wahrscheinlich dann
eventuell einfach ein Level Abstraktion
zu viel oder sowas. Aber das stimmt.
Das ist wieder gefährliches Halbwissen
noch auf meiner Seite. Also auch diese Robert-Koch-Institut
Corona-App, die ist ja auch eine
Flutter-App und das fühlst du dir richtig hart an.
Obwohl Flutter doch eigentlich so
Google hat doch die Ambition,
dass Flutter so das nächste
Main-Ding für Android-Entwicklung
sein sollte, oder?
Das rendert ja wieder komplett selbst.
Das macht ja komplett, glaube ich,
nagel mich nicht drauf fest, war das irgendwie OpenGL-basiert
oder so? Das ist ja ein komplett eigener Rendering-Stack.
Auf iOS, meinst du dann?
Ja,
vielleicht überall. Ich bin mir
nicht mehr sicher. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass
die vielleicht einfach keine super flotte
iOS-Integration bereits haben, sondern
das ist erstmal für Android. Aber die Android-Apps fühle ich ja auch nicht
flott, flott an. Die sind anders.
Okay.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns...
Zur Handhabung wie der Navigation-Stack oder so,
der halt irgendwie anders ist, irgendwie,
weiß nicht. Vielleicht sollten wir uns mal Leute
aus der Developers-
Gruppe einladen,
dass die uns mal aufklären können, was der Unterschied
zwischen Flutter und
React Native und Native
ist. Die technischen Unterschiede
sind ja, also da können wir auch selber drüber philosophieren,
aber ja, wir sollten mal mit Leuten, die
mehr Ahnung davon haben. Leute, die es tatsächlich mal benutzt haben,
Und das ist Samarin, auch noch cool.
Aber das ist ja wirklich quasi Elektron auf dem Telefon, oder?
Nee, nee, nee.
Samarin ist ja fast noch der nativste Ansatzgefühl davon gewesen.
Aber da hast du doch auch bloß Web-Technologien verwendet,
oder war das nicht so?
Nee, das war die Sharp-Krams, was du da machst.
Ach so.
Du denkst an PhoneGap wahrscheinlich.
Eventuell.
Das war WebFu, reinster WebFu.
So wie die DVB-App zum Beispiel.
Das ist eine PhoneGap.
Nee, das heißt ja mittlerweile anders.
Ionic oder so.
Oder das ist ähnliches.
Also PhoneGap heißt ja auch nicht mehr.
Phone gehabt, das hieß irgendwie dann anders, aber Ionic
ist derselbe, fuhr bloß ein anderer Titel.
Ah ja, es gibt also zumindest eine ganze
Menge Arten und Weisen Apps zu
bauen, die nicht nativ sind.
Irgendwie.
Ja, das hast du gesagt jetzt mit dem Nativ-Label.
Tja, nativ,
das ist ja die Frage.
Wir nehmen schon seit fast anderthalb Stunden auf,
wollen wir mal langsam zu den Picks übergehen.
Ja,
sehr gerne, dann sparen wir uns
noch ein bisschen was für die nächste Folge auf.
du fängst an
okay
warte mal, ich mach jetzt mal die Kapitelmarke
ja
dann fang ich auch gleich mal an
ich hab hier ein Projekt, das heißt
Ruma TUI
das ist Ruma Terminal UI
das ist ein Matrix Client
aufbauend auf den Ruma Crates
und diesem richtig fancy
tollen TUI Crate
für Rust, was dir
die Möglichkeit gibt, auf dem Terminal richtig fancy
UIs zu bauen. Also fancy UIs
auf dem Terminal finde ich immer geil, ob das jetzt
Curses-Fu ist oder auf einer anderen
Basis, aber das Ding sieht auch echt schick aus.
Und dadurch, dass der auf den Humalips aufbaut,
kann das quasi schon, das ist quasi fertig,
so wie das Ding ausschaut. Und es ist ein richtig schicker
Terminal-Matrix-Client, finde ich einfach nur geil.
Also dieses TUI-RS,
hatte ich auch manchmal gesehen, das kann irgendwie so
das kann unterschiedliche
Views ineinander schachteln, dann kannst du
irgendwie geile Grafiken malen und
Balkendiagramme und
Layouting und Gauges und Karten
und was weiß ich nicht alles.
Karten vor allem, das ist mindblown.
Aber
trotzdem bist du ja da einigermaßen beschränkt
auf so eine Zeile Text pro
Ding. Du kannst ja jetzt nichts kleinteilig
... Ich frage mich dann, wie sehen
zum Beispiel Reactions in sowas
aus?
Hast du das mal ausprobiert? Hast du es tatsächlich mal benutzt?
Ich habe es noch nicht installiert, aber ich sehe gerade,
der hat mittlerweile einen Install-Hinweis
für Cargo-Install-Humatui.
Achso, nee, da steht not yet.
Not yet. Okay, dann warten wir also,
bis man es benutzen kann. Da steht noch
Work in Progress Command Line Matrix.
Das ist ja typisch, du hast einfach
klonen, cargo, build, äh, nee,
run und dann läuft.
Ja, ich meine, unser
wir haben eine tatsächlich sicher
verschlüsselte Konversation in
Matrix hat ja auch bloß einen Tag
gehalten, bis du dann wieder irgendeinen anderen Client
hinzugefügt hattest. Wir hatten uns echt
20 Minuten damit auseinandergesetzt.
irgendwie alle unsere Clients gegenseitig miteinander
zu verifizieren.
Das müssen wir jetzt am Ende der Folge nochmal machen.
Es sind ja bloß fünfmal vier Clients gewesen oder so,
20 einzelne Verifikationen, die wir da durchführen mussten.
Das war ja unglaublich anstrengend.
Gibt es mittlerweile einen ETA für,
wie heißt das Feature?
Cross-Signing? Gibt es.
Rate mal wann.
2021.
Morgen. Echt jetzt?
Ja, sollte eigentlich am Donnerstag schon launchen,
haben sie aber nochmal auf Montag verschoben.
Funktioniert in fast allen Fällen
sehr zuverlässig.
Außer in Romadui.
Nee, da muss ich aber darauf warten,
dass mein Homeserver das unterstützt
oder muss ich darauf warten, dass mein Client
das mit unterstützt? Also was heißt morgen?
Morgen kommt das in Riot oder wie?
Morgen soll das,
also
eigentlich eine gute Frage, so wie ich das verstanden
habe, kommt morgen das Synapse Release,
was das mitbringt.
Beziehungsweise, warte mal,
muss der Homeserver überhaupt was tun dafür?
Kann sein, dass das ein rein Client-Feature ist.
Ich glaube beides.
Ich glaube, du brauchst ein Synapse und ein Riot-Update dafür.
Und die Sachen, die von Matrix-Orc gehostet werden,
die werden das dann dementsprechend relativ schnell ausrollen,
weil die wollen das ja auch.
Das ist ja ein riesiger Schmerzpunkt.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das Feature
einfach schon deaktiviert in deinem aktuellen Riot drin ist.
Es ist schon drin.
Du kannst es in den Labs aktuell schon aktivieren,
wenn du möchtest.
Wenn du auf Riot.im bist.
Da kannst du es schon aktivieren.
Aber was halt zusätzlich damit kommt, was ich auch sehr cool finde, ist E2EE End-to-End Encryption by Default. Sprich jede neue Direktnachricht, Räume nicht, öffentliche Räume willst du ja eigentlich teilweise auch nicht verschlüsseln, aber Direktnachrichten idealerweise immer. Und das kommt auch, dass es per Default an ist und nicht per Default aus.
Nice. Das heißt, dieses rote
Warning-Logo in unserem Chat
geht dann einfach von alleine weg.
Das geht dann weg,
sobald du deine Clients verifiziert hast.
Also ich muss einfach bloß alle meine
Clients und wenn ich einen neuen Client hinzufüge,
muss ich meine eigenen Clients miteinander
händisch
ververifizieren?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, weil
sonst ist der Angriffsvektor ja potenziell
noch offen, dass ein anderer sich als du ausgeben
könntest. Stimmt, ich muss sagen, das ist wirklich
aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass genau wie jetzt läuft,
du meldest dich mit einem neuen Client an und dann geht
auf einem deiner anderen Clients, solange das Riot ist
aktuell, aber bei anderen modernen Clients
auch, geht dann ein Pop-Up auf von wegen, hey, du hast
eine neue Session mit einem neuen Client, willst du die
Encryption-Keys teilen, klickst da auf Ja
und dann war's das. Cool.
Sehr schön. Da freue ich mich schon.
Und wenn du dich nicht neu angemeldet hast, klickst du da nicht auf Ja,
weil sonst hast du gerade einen Eingreifer reingelassen.
Etch.
Cool. Na, dann freue ich mich doch auf morgen.
Da habe ich doch was, worauf ich mich freuen kann.
Ich hoffe, es launcht wirklich dann morgen. Wenn nicht, dann wird es in den
nächsten Tagen auf jeden Fall passieren. Also die haben eine
im aktuellen This Week in Matrix war
von Matthew und Amandine. Die haben
beide das mal gedemot
im Video live.
Seit wann gibt es eigentlich diese ganzen
This Week in
Blogs? Es ist eine herrliche Geschichte,
ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde die großartig.
Vor allem, ich finde die Art
und Weise, wie es gesammelt wird bei This Week in Matrix
geil. Es gibt halt den TWIM, This Week in Matrix
Raum und wenn du da halt
Dinge schreibst und den TWIM
Bot mentionst, dann fügt er das halt
direkt in eine Liste und Ben
der Ben von Matrix, der geht halt
jeden Freitag durch, schaut sich diese Liste an und schreibt
da einen Blogpost, wo er das alles einfach durchsammelt.
Das heißt, die ganze Woche übersammelt einfach Leute
da in dem Raum Dinge, Menschen in den
Twimbot, kriegen Cookie-Reactions dafür
und freuen sich. Cool. Finde ich
schön. Cool, cool. Nice.
Was hast denn du als Pick?
Was hab ich denn als Pick? Also, ich hab eine
ziemlich witzige Single-Purpose-Webseite
gefunden, für alle Leute,
die zu Hause arbeiten, aber eigentlich lieber
im Büro arbeiten würden, weil es irgendwie im Büro
eine schönere Atmosphäre gibt.
Es gibt imistheoffice.eu
und
ich mach die mal ganz kurz auf.
Wenn du die bei dir auch parallel aufmachst,
die lädt leider etwas langsam, denn
das ist so eine geile WebGL 3D
Geschichte und was du da
machen kannst, ist, du kannst irgendwie aus unten rechts
so einen Counter Number of Colleagues, da kannst du
Plus und Minus drücken
und was das Ding dann macht, ist, dass es einfach
im Raum verteilte
zufällige
Bürogeräusche abspielt. Da hast du dann
die Leute, die irgendwo ein bisschen was labern.
Das ist, glaube ich, manchmal auch italienisch oder spanisch,
keine Ahnung. Oh Gott, ich habe die Kopiere angeklickt.
Und dann kannst du irgendwie hier unterschiedliche Geräte
anklicken, die machen dann diese Geräusche, die da
abgebildet sind. Es gibt
auch einen Watercooler, der blubbert dann so ein bisschen.
Ja.
Also ich dachte erst, als du die Domain...
Oh, wie cool. Es könnte auch was anderes
sein.
Genau, und das ist einfach so ein bisschen
Soundscape. Ach, das dauert ja ewig.
und dann kannst du unterschiedliche Kollegen an
das in dem Podcast jemand gepinkelt hat
genau und das kannst du so ein bisschen im Hintergrund
laufen lassen, dann bist du nicht ganz so einsam
das ist so ein bisschen wie Coffee-Tivity
falls du Coffee-Tivity
noch kennst, das ist einfach ein
Online-Radio mit Geräuschen aus einem Kaffee
wo du so das Hintergrund geprabbelt hast
das Problem bei solchen Sachen ist, das kannst du halt
mal zum Spaß eine halbe Stunde nebenbei anmachen
und dann wiederholen sich die Samples
und du merkst es sofort.
Das ist wie dieser Regen-
und Gewitter-Stream, wo du
nach einer halben Stunde das gleiche
Donnern wieder erkennst. Also das ist so ein bisschen traurig.
Aber das hier
fand ich eigentlich ziemlich witzig
und man kann sich das mal angucken.
Es ist sogar so plastisch, ich merke gerade, man kann
diese Karte sogar drehen, wenn man hier
Drag & Drop macht.
Das ist tatsächlich eine echt schicke 3D-Hansicht.
Ich finde es optisch sehr ansprechend.
Ich dachte erst, als du
ins Bett gepostet hast, dass es um die Serie
The Office geht, weil die vermisse ich auch.
Ja,
allerdings.
Aber nee, hier geht es tatsächlich um so diese Arbeitsatmosphäre
für die ganzen Work-from-Home-Leute,
die
irgendwie ihre Einsamkeit
ein bisschen vor sich her schieben.
Genau, du bist wieder dran.
Ich habe
noch von der
großartigen GitHub-Org
Swift-Doc-Org, von der
Seite SwiftDoc, wo unter anderem
Nate,
komm gar nicht, nee, Matt
und Nate, ich komme nicht auf die Nachnamen von denen,
die spielt auch keine Rolle, Matt mit 3T,
ist immer sehr eindeutig.
Die haben die Seite NSSipster am Laufen
gehabt, super tolle Seite
und die
maintainen auch SwiftDoc.org
für SwiftDocumentation, aber nur für die
Documentation der Standard Library, deswegen ist die auch ein bisschen
schmal, aber die haben
ein tolles Tool rausgebracht,
vor allem Matt, ich weiß nicht, wie inwiefern der Nate überhaupt noch
dabei ist, das heißt Doctest.
Und das macht genau das, was du denkst. Man kennt es aus der Python-Welt,
man kennt es aus der Rust-Welt,
dass du Documentation hast
an deinen Funktionen zum Beispiel mit Beispiel
aufrufen oder in der Readme
Beispielcode. Und dieser
Code ist halt in der Dokumentation
geschrieben und deswegen halt
normalerweise ein Kommentar oder in der Readme halt
komplett außerhalb vom Code und wird halt
nicht ausgeführt und nicht verifiziert,
dass der überhaupt baut und vor allem nicht verifiziert,
dass die Beispiele halt auch valide sind.
und DocTest macht genau das,
was nach der Name klingt, du testest
das mit. Du siehst, dass Code
in der Dokumentation geschrieben ist, du führst diesen Code
aus und das finde ich großartig. Ich wollte es schon länger
für Swift haben und jetzt existiert es auch.
Die machen halt einfach nur geil.
Das ist ein extra Tool
oder ist das, was du
dann laufen lässt?
Das gehört mit zu der Dokumentationsgeneration?
Also Swift hat auch
keine Dokumentationsgeneration eingebaut.
Das ist ein extra Tool. Sie haben das Tool
SwiftDoc geschrieben und es gibt jetzt auch noch das
Doctest-Tool.
Die installieren sich quasi wie Cargo-Plugins
oftmals auch als Swift-Dash-Name,
sodass du es genauso auch nutzen kannst.
SwiftDoc-Test dann dementsprechend.
Da habe ich auch letztens mein Tool Swift
outdated geschrieben, was ähnlich zu Cargo outdated
dem Plugin dir angibt,
welche der Dependencies outdated sind.
Und das macht,
genau, so läuft das extra Tool und
wird dann losgelassen auf
deinen Quelltext.
Ziemlich nice. Hast du mal ein Beispiel davon,
wie das aussieht, wenn es generiert ist?
Die SwiftDoc,
die sieht aus typischerweise wie so eine
Jazzy-Dokumentation. Jazzy ist
ein altes Tool aus der iOS-Welt,
was das macht.
Wo habe ich denn ein Beispiel? Ich glaube,
ich habe sogar ein Beispiel irgendwo für
einen meiner alten.
Nee, ich find grad kein Story.
Ja, da kannst du ja vielleicht an die Show Notes anhängen.
Ich, äh,
vielleicht noch zu deiner Erheiterung, weil ich
hab nicht viel Neues zu Dino zu erzählen,
aber ich schau ab und zu mal hin und Dino
hat vor ein paar Tagen gelauncht,
dass es jetzt auch doc.dino.land
gibt. Die schauen sich
die richtigen Sachen aus der Rust-Community ab.
Äh, und da hast du
für die Sachen, die irgendwie auf Dino selber,
auf Dino Land selber gelauncht,
gehostet sind, so wie deren Standardbibliothek,
aber auch manche externe Sachen,
hast du einfach generiert
der Doc und es ist glaube ich nicht einfach bloß TypeDoc,
sondern es ist eventuell irgendwas eigenes.
Ich lage mich da jetzt nicht fest.
Aber wenn du einfach auf doc.dino.land
gehst, hast du so eine Liste
Samples, dann klickst du jetzt mal auf irgendwas,
was weiß ich, dinoland.dino.land.ox.oak.ts
und diese Ladeanimation,
die du dann siehst, wenn du drauf klickst.
Hast du es zufällig gerade gemacht?
Ich habe es nicht auf...
Geh mal auf...
nur deine Beschreibung
gelauscht.
Wie schreibt man die nur nochmal?
Deno, wie No rückwärts oder halb rückwärts.
Halb rückwärts,
also D-N-O.
D-E-N-O.
Achso, so war das.
Das da.
Oh, die Ladermission war viel zu kurz.
Kann ich sagen.
Cute.
Das sind einfach solche zwei Dinos,
die so durch die Gegend schreien.
Das ist ja auch das Maskottchen schon geworden,
dieser süße Brontosaurus,
glaube ich. Bin mir aber nicht sicher.
Wenn es einen Brontosaurus
jemals gab, es kann auch sein,
dass irgendwie, ich glaube, Brontosaurus war
einer, den sie zufällig falsch zusammengesteckt haben
und den gab es gar nicht so richtig.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, da war auch was.
Aber geil, Doc-Generatoren. Wir brauchen
mehr davon. Und ich hätte auch
gerne Hosted Documentation, aber sowas setzt ein bisschen
voraus, also so einen generellen Service.
Du brauchst eine zentrale Registry, von der du das abweist.
Ja, sowas setzt ein bisschen eben die Registry voraus
und sowas haben wir halt noch nicht in der Swift-Welt
so traurig, so traurig, so traurig.
Es gibt so ein bisschen
swiftpm.co ist so eine aktuell
sehr populäre Seite, die dafür genutzt wird.
Aber das ist halt
auch nur von einem,
also in dem Fall bekannteren Menschen
aus der Community, aber es ist halt trotzdem nur die Seite
von einem Privatprojekt quasi.
Ist halt die Frage, was wäre
denn ein offizielles Projekt? Wer müsste
hinter sowas stehen?
Ja, Apple dementsprechend, oder?
Ja, that's not gonna happen.
Oder ein ausgelagertes Swift Org.
Mal schauen, vielleicht tut sich ja da irgendwann mal was.
Genau.
Was habe ich noch als Pick?
Ich hatte noch das Spaßprojekt DNS over Wikipedia.
Das habe ich auch gesehen, das habe ich noch nicht gerafft.
Kannst du mir das bitte erklären?
Es ist einfach super geil.
Die haben einfach einen kleinen Service,
lässt sich lokal laufen, interessanterweise in Was geschrieben,
der schaut, ob du als DNS Anfragen an eine nicht existierende TLD
namens IDK für I don't know schickst.
Und wenn du in deinem Browser zum Beispiel auf scihub.idk gehst,
dann macht der im Hintergrund nichts anderes,
als die Domain davon auf der Wikipedia zu suchen,
die kanonische URL davon zu nehmen und dich an die weiterzuleiten.
Weil Wikipedia halt möglicherweise die bessere Quelle dafür ist.
Wenn du zum Beispiel scihub googlest,
dann findest du diverse outdated Domains.
Aber wenn du scihub.idk öffnest,
dann geht er auf Wikipedia davon
und leitet dich direkt auf scihub-hub.tv.
was zur aktuellen Zeit
was heute zufällig die Top-Level-Domain
davon ist, genau. Ja, finde ich aber
geil, das über I-Don't-Know zu machen, über
quasi als
so wie Leute halt, keine Ahnung,
man sieht ja mal manchen Leuten, die zum Beispiel
Facebook googeln, weil sie nicht
die Domain eingeben
wollen und die Daten noch
an Google weiterreichen, was sie da eben machen,
macht dein Browser potenziell halt nebenher. Trotzdem,
wenn du Tipps, aber wenn du Chrome benutzt.
Das gab es mal als Service
von der Telekom, da
mich irgendwie mal, da ist tatsächlich mal irgendwie
eine böse E-Mail hingeschrieben oder sowas,
dass dir die Default in deiner,
wenn du einen Telekom-Account hast,
oder die als ISP verwendest, dann
die irgendwie in deiner Account-Einstellung
standardmäßig, wenn du irgendwie was
eingegeben hast, was keine valide Domain war,
da haben sie dich zu einer Telekom-Suchseite
weitergeleitet und haben es dort gesucht.
Ekelhaft. Ja, genau, das konntest
du da abschalten, aber das war mal eine Zeit lang
Default-mäßig an.
Aber abgefahren, DNS over Wikipedia, sehr schön.
Mich würde langsam
wann Sci-Hub mit allen TLDs durch ist,
wann die irgendwann Sachen wiederverwenden müssen.
Ja, und The Pirate Bay, keine Ahnung,
das ist das selbe Problem.
Das ist schon ein bisschen bitter.
Ich hätte noch einen
Kulturtipp, und zwar
habe ich einen schönen YouTube-Channel gefunden,
der heißt Context Free,
den habe ich auch,
da musst du auch wirklich wach sein,
wenn du das guckst,
das ist einer, der einfach
über Programmiersprachen redet,
und der vergleicht dann, sie hat ein Video,
das Modulsystem von
C++, wie es
in C++20 kommen soll,
mit dem von Python, mit dem von Haskell,
mit dem von Rust, mit dem von Swift
vergleicht.
Und das ist quasi akronomisierbar
plus auf hohem Niveau und nur
über Programmiersprache und mit Bildern.
Und mit einem
lustigen
englischen Dialekt.
Cool, das schauen wir auf jeden Fall rein.
Vor allem das Namespace Modules in Rust,
SIG, C++, C++20,
JavaScript, SIG,
also habe ich schon, Ruby, Elixir und Rust
und Python. Das ist wieder
spannend. Hat Zwift eigentlich Namespaces
gehabt? Ich habe für
meinen Vortrag bei der C++ User Group
hatte ich mal nebeneinander gestellt,
Rust-Module versus C++-Module
und für den Kontext habe ich mich überhaupt
zum ersten Mal mit C++-Modulen auseinandergesetzt,
die ja jetzt in C++20
kommen. Und das Problem ist, dass
C++ bereits Namespaces hat
und dementsprechend haben sie den Namespacing-Aspekt
aus Modulen einfach komplett weggelassen.
Das heißt, du kannst bei C++-Modulen
an einer einzelnen Header-Datei sagen,
diese Header-Datei exportiert dieses Modul
und dann schreibst du an Sachen Export ran,
die du exportiert haben möchtest,
musst die aber trotzdem noch in Namespaces packen
und die Namespaces können halt wie bei C
auch auf unterschiedliche Dateien verteilt sein.
Das ist sehr witzig.
Also wenn Module und Namespaces nicht das gleiche sind,
kann es zu einigen Verwirrungen führen.
Also Swift hat ein Konzept von Modulen.
Und also Module generell, was heißt das?
Von der Idee von Packages oder auch Frameworks
läuft das ja auf eine gewisse Weise hinaus.
Namespaces in dem Sinne, das ist dann quasi ein Namespace.
Aber ansonsten missbrauchen Leute Zero-Case-Enums
als Namespaces auch oftmals.
Was ein bisschen schade ist,
aber so ist es halt jetzt.
Bei TypeScript gab es tatsächlich Namespaces,
die sich so verhalten haben wie C-Namespaces,
dass sie sich nämlich über mehrere Module verteilen konnten.
Und die haben dann im Global Namespace rumgeschrieben
und sich dort irgendwie registriert,
damit du irgendwie über die Namespaces auf Sachen zugreifen konntest
und haben sich ein bisschen orthogonal zu JavaScript verhalten.
Und deswegen sind Namespaces in TypeScript mittlerweile auch deprecated.
Du sollst die bitte nicht mehr verwenden, was sehr wichtig ist.
Aber das, was wir haben in Swift, würde ich auch noch sagen,
ist immerhin besser als das, was es vorher
in Objective-C gab, nämlich gar keine
Namespaces, in den Leads dergleichen,
wo du durch
zwei Liter, drei Liter Prefixes
an Klassen, das dir alles
gemacht hast. Alles ist besser
als keine Namespaces.
Obwohl,
vielleicht auch nicht, ich weiß das nicht.
Und dann habe ich noch eine schöne
Übersicht, die
wir an diesem Podcast auch bereits
semi-erfolgreich verwendet haben.
Es gibt nämlich eine schöne von GDS, wo stand das eigentlich nochmal?
Es gab eine schöne Übersicht, Government Digital Services aus dem UK, gds.blog.gov.uk,
hat dann eine schöne Übersicht für Handzeichen für Videokonferenzen, die haben wir an dieser Stelle schon verwendet.
Einfach so, wenn du nonverbal während einer Videokonferenz kommunizierst, während einer redet,
was ja mit dem Inswort Fallen,
was manchmal delaybedingt etwas schwierig ist.
Genau, haben die eine Liste von Handzeichen.
Du irritierst mich, indem du dir einfach der Reihe nach gerade hast.
Eine Reihe von Handzeichen deklariert.
Und die Handzeichen sind einfach, schaut es euch an,
aber es sind Handzeichen für I agree, I don't agree,
I want to talk, I have a direct response,
please clarify und point of order.
Und das ist tatsächlich, wenn man das so einmal in einem Meeting einführt oder vor einem Podcast, durchaus hilfreich.
Bei dem Point of Order habe ich direkt diesen, mir fällt sein Name leider nicht ein, vom englischen Parlament im Kopf, der bei Last Week Tonight halt auch sehr oft gezeigt wird.
Der hat die immer so im Hintergrund reinbrüllt.
Order! Order!
Achso, der ist denn der Typ. Auf jeden Fall.
Was ich beim englischen Parlament lustig finde, ist, dass die nicht, die dürfen nicht klatschen.
das war denen zu
bourgeois
und deswegen
zu bürgerlich und deswegen
schreien die die ganze Zeit
I
und rufen rein. Du darfst laut reinrufen,
wenn du eben zustimmst, aber du darfst nicht
applaudieren.
Die haben so
dumme Konzepte da.
Auch die Art und Weise, wie sie da sitzen und sich anbrüllen
und teilweise auch handgreiflich werden,
das sieht halt alles andere als nach Zivilisation
aus, finde ich. Aber das Geilste ist ja immer noch
das, was sie bei Last Week Tonight auch immer wieder ansprechen,
ist, dass du Aufnahmen aus dem Parlament
nicht im Fernsehen zeigen
darfst. Nee, nee, du darfst sie nicht in Comedy-Sendungen
zeigen. Ach so, im
Comedy-Kontext, oder? Du darfst sie nicht im Comedy-Kontext
zeigen. Du darfst sie im Fernsehen zeigen, aber
Last Week Tonight zählt als Comedy-Sendung, deswegen
dürfen sie dort ausgerechnet keine Sachen
zeigen. Also zumindest nicht im
Englischen. Deswegen haben sie dann, wenn sie es
im UK ausstrahlen, machen sie da irgendwie
russisches Ballett rein an den Stellen.
Irgendwas Dummes immer, aber
ist so absurd bescheuert, einfach nur solche
Regeln. Auf jeden Fall.
Naja.
Ja, das waren so meine Pics.
Ja, meine auch.
Sehr cool.
Und alles, was wir jetzt noch nicht abgehackt haben, schieben wir
dann einfach in die nächste Folge rein.
Genau, dann haben wir noch ein bisschen Stoff.
Ist doch wunderbar.
Genau, also ich hoffe, diesmal hat das mit der Auflage
einigermaßen geklappt. Wir haben jetzt dieses Mal
erfolgreich Studio Link mit LAN verwendet.
Ich habe mich extra ans LAN
angeschlossen. Ich habe Kilian explizit gebeten,
den Adapter aus dem
Schubfach rauszuholen und
latenzmäßig klang es eigentlich,
war es eigentlich ganz okay, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin auch begeistert. Das fühlt sich richtig gut
an. Ich habe auch ein besseres Mikrofon heute hier stehen.
Sorry für die Aufnahmequalität beim letzten Mal.
Das war ein bisschen spontan remote
entstanden. Ja, die Airpods
sind leider einfach ein bisschen zu weit weg vom Mund,
um gut genug zu klingen. Das merkt
man auch immer, wenn ich mir
hier Late Show mit Stephen
Colbert angucke, der hat ja auch die ersten Folgen
irgendwie in seinem Garten
mit Airpods gemacht und das klingt
einfach nicht gut genug. Es liegt
einfach physikalisch daran, dass das Mikro
zu weit weg vom Mund ist, leider.
Aber ich habe jetzt tatsächlich,
mir tut so ein bisschen leid für
den Mick, der bei unserer
Folge, die erste Remote
Studio Link Folge Richtung
Schottland dabei war
und es leider ein bisschen verkackt klang
bei ihm oder dass wir so eine große Latenz hatten,
das würde wahrscheinlich
beim nächsten Mal besser funktionieren. Aber bei ihm kam ja noch
das Problem mit dem defekten Mikrofon dazu,
wo selbst seine Lokalaufnahmen
haben. Wir lernen ja auch aus unseren Fehlern.
Genau.
Genau, ein Erratum haben wir by the way noch.
Können wir noch mit erwähnen. Danke Helge für das Feedback,
dass Postscript natürlich
keine Apple-Sache war, sondern von Adobe.
Und dass das erfunden wurde,
weil man 1990
keine 1200 dpi in endlicher
Zeit übertragen konnte im Netzwerk.
Deswegen schickt man Daten darüber.
Und was ich ein sehr cooles Detail fand,
war das Next Step, das
auch fürs Rendern der UI verwendet hat.
Das war DisplayPostScript, was
den coolen Nebeneffekt hatte,
dass du ein Screenshot in 1200
dpi einfach ausdrucken konntest.
Wie geil ist das?
Hat deshalb Apple bei jedem Programm
eingebaut, diese Druckfunktion, dass du
eigentlich aus jedem Programm raus
drucken kannst? Das kann
sein, dass es noch eine Legacy-API daher ist,
dass es halt existiert, dass du jeden View direkt
printen kannst.
Dass es vielleicht noch aus der Zeit mit, zumindest
Naja, der Drucker ist der Vorfrage vom Bildschirm am Computer. Und viele Leute haben auch immer noch, das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, einen Drucker auf dem Schreibtisch stehen. Hast du einen Drucker auf dem Schreibtisch stehen, Köln?
Ich besitze keinen Drucker.
Ich besitze auch keinen Drucker, hätte ich gesagt.
Ich hatte ja letztens das Problem, dass ich für meine amerikanische Steuererklärung noch ein paar Formulare einschicken musste.
Und die habe ich mir dann bei einem Online-Copy-Shop bestellt, weil die Copyshops dank Corona, wieder bei dem Thema, alle schon geschlossen hatten.
Und andere Formulare, die ich noch brauchte für andere Sachen, die auch postalisch rausgehen mussten, habe ich mir dann einfach schnell auf meiner Schreibmaschine zusammengehackt.
Stimmt, das Bild habe ich auf Twitter gesehen, das sah sehr herrlich aus.
Ich hätte mir solche Sachen dann immer im Büro gedruckt,
aber das geht jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Dementsprechend
weiß ich gerade gar nicht, wie ich was drucken würde.
Wahrscheinlich bei irgendeinem
Nachbarn mir das dann abholen oder sowas,
bei irgendeinem Kumpel, der auf der Ecke wohnt.
Aber bei dir muss ich ja offenbar nicht anfragen.
Sorry,
ich besitze sowas nicht.
Vor allem Drucker managen willst du halt auch nicht.
Dann brauchst du Farbe oder Toner
und Papier und dann staut das.
Dann musst du gucken,
es klingt das Ding nach Ozon.
Dann musst du gucken, obwohl das ist eigentlich okay,
aber dann musst du gucken, ob du für deinen
Lilux, ob du die richtigen Treiber hast,
musst du das einrichten.
Das war alles scheiße.
Das Drucker sind eigentlich immer kacke, auf jeden Fall.
Gut, dann haben wir jetzt, glaube ich,
einen Punkt erreicht.
Ich würde mich sehr freuen,
dich mal wieder in Persona zu treffen, aber
ich glaube, das funktioniert auch so ganz gut.
Wir sehen uns hier zumindest über Video nebenbei.
Ich musste leider deine eigene Mate trinken,
es tut mir leid.
typisches Homeoffice-Problem, man muss
seine eigene Mate plötzlich trinken.
Sehr traurig.
Na gut, dann
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, liebe Zuhörer.
Es war uns ein Fest.
Das war akronomisierbar
Folge 40.
Wir sind bei 40 schon. Das heißt, wir sind noch
10 Folgen entfernt zu 50.
Und dann haben wir schon die Hälfte der 100.
Und wenn wir die 100 schaffen, haben wir schon
ein Zehntel unseres allgemeinen Podcast-Budgets.
weil wir können nur bis Folge 999 aufnehmen.
Mehr geht nicht.
Stimmt, wir haben bloß dreistellige Zahlen.
Wir müssen uns einfach das Commitment machen.
Ab Folge 999 werden wir einfach mit Akronomisierbar aufhören.
Ja, das wird die letzte Folge.
Das Ende ist in Sicht.
Ich glaube, wir werden dann unsere eigene Episode
bei Fall of Civilizations bekommen.
Wenn wir grob so eine monatliche Folge rausbringen,
sind das auch nur gerade 80 Jahre und dann sind wir halt durch.
Also 80 Jahre schaffe ich noch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber
die 80 Jahre geht noch.
Die nächsten 80 Jahre, jeden Monat
eine Folge.
Gut, okay, also vielen lieben Dank beim Zuhören.
Liebe Zuhörer, bleibt gesund.
Schreibt uns mal, wo ihr eure
MNSS herbekommt.
Ich habe mir, wie gesagt,
ursprünglich selber welche genäht und
bin aber jetzt doch sehr froh, dass ich mir eine
Professionelle bei einem lokalen Schneider,
einer lokalen Schneiderin kaufen konnte.
Aber vielleicht kriegen wir auch Tipps von
euch.
Das war, wie gesagt, Folge 40 und
du machst mal den Countdown.
Wir hängen uns ja eh auf den Endkürt jetzt hier auf.
Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich sagte auch noch mal.
Der nächste
Podcast mit eurem Podcatcher kommt in
3, 2,
1.